I go through TSA get through my little
you know little thing get on the plane
and I sit down and I never forget that
smell when I sat down I was like oh my
going to jail I'm going to jail I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
ffect
perfect
[Music]
perfect yo what's up guys dope as Yol
here Thomas whatever you want to call me
this is the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys and today today's the day you've
been asking for since episode one season
1 non-stop every day thousand times a
day guys this is the burner episode
thank you for being here man you know
I'm glad that they asked for it cuz I
I've been Wan you know look you get what
you ask for man Clos mouth don't get
fast outout to the audience being it's
it's we do all the comments we do every
comment up to to a
th000 so it's I mean there's thousands
of and we've done hundreds of episodes
there's 10,000 comments asking for it so
here it is man I'm finally I'm I'm
stoked and uh let's just start smoking
because there's no reason to not we
already know what we could talk about
it's going to get us in trouble probably
so yo you heard of this toad Venom uh I
have not what is it toad Venom no this
this is from uh canopy
Builders Ronin
seeds boom Ronin seeds Canon uh candy
Builders what is that right there what's
it what's the cross on
that I gotta be honest he
knows he knows tast like a like a little
gassy it tastes like a Cactus Cooler to
me a little candy
gas I like it
dude all right let's get started let's
get started all right so I wanted to
start this off this is the way I was
going to do this episode
cuz you're not out there doing a 50
[__] interviews you're not you're
just not so there's I've seen you you
went on drink Champs that's obviously
going to be about music that's obviously
going to be about this and when do weed
stuff we smoke weed but this is not the
weed show you know what I mean I guess
saying that right now but I wanted to
take this as steps like fan what a fan
would want to know what I would want to
know as a fan cuz Marty what did I say
when I got here oh I left all my [__] M
I know I I was I got my little brother
my nephew here so my wife took him to
Universal I was all like going I forgot
all my CDs oh [__] I have all CDs like
all the signed ones I wanted to bust him
out and [__] but it's okay I forgot him
but as a fan I wanted to weave us
through there weave us through the
industry current so that's how I kind of
wanted to take this let's do it but
let's start it off at the beginning
you're from uh Frisco San Francisco yeah
all right Born and Raised born and
raised well I was actually born in Daily
City um you know little little far from
SF but then we moved to SF um my father
had a restaurant right there on Filmore
in
California uh we lived on top of that
restaurant so we had a little Studio
apartment um and I would bounce back and
forth uh from there to a so spent most
of my time like early childhood in Daily
City which was really cool you know it
was Bay Area but like kind of like
suburb get a chance to like actually
play with kids in a neighborhood and
[__] like that you're not in a big city
and then from fifth grade moved to
Arizona from fifth to like ninth grade
and then around 9th grade I bounced back
and forth from AZ to my Dad's apartment
in in San Francisco which was on top of
his restaurant which is that's when I
kind of started get in a lot of trouble
and [__] like that pops was kind of like
a loose he didn't really monitor to me
as much as my mom did so grew up between
Daily city um Arizona and SF why Arizona
and how boring bro well Arizona was
interesting bro like really what what
part I mean just I lived in Chandler but
I I hung out into like Tempe Phoenix and
[__] like that and Arizona like made me
grow up fast when I left Daily City in
fifth grade I was still kind of like
innocent kid I was just chilling I was
into like you know fantasy of like what
I want to be when I'm older I'm just
thinking about all these crazy things I
used to want to be a rock star and
things like that and then I get to
Arizona as fol as are selling acid and
selling weed and like chicks were doing
[__] Coke in class I'm like yo
Arizona was wild cuz the suburbs are
turned up and there's a lot of you know
a lot of [__] going on in Arizona so it
kind of like made me grow up kind of
fast uh but Arizona was boring but not
really though it was exciting cuz like
the smirk on your face say you got into
some [__] yeah I got into a lot of [__]
in Arizona it was it was fun at the time
probably wasn't the smartest [__] in the
world but it was fine all right damn see
the same thing happen me I got kicked
out got to go to Oregon so I had to go
experience all those other b or is
boring it's cool it's just boring so you
went to Arizona what was the move why uh
when my dad kind of like we owned a
Mexican restaurant you know I always
went to San Francisco so just cuz I
lived in da City didn't mean that I
wasn't at my father's restaurant all the
time that was in the city so I did kind
of grow up in the city in a sense um but
he was knowing he kind of knew that
Arizona was like a booming market and
there was a lot of growth happening
that's before like it kind of like got
what it is today and he wanted to open
up restaurant out there it kind of
convinced my Mom like yo we should open
the restaurant out there and we were
going to move out there together and I
guess pops got caught cheating when
we're about to leave and we're in the
car I'll never forget we're in the car
on the way I'm like yo when's dad coming
and she was like he's not like what do
you mean she was like we're going to do
our own thing for a while I'm like what
the [__] does that even mean she was
like he's going to stay back home I was
like oh okay this is pretty that's how
you found out I found out in the car in
the car in the car on the way in a hot
ass
U-Haul yeah D family was moving driving
through the desert sticky my whole
family's mover so I grew up in a damn
truck so I I know that feeling dude but
it was it was weird I I remember like
like it was yesterday I remember getting
there to the house and like looking at
this house in the suburbs and like
looking at the new neighborhood and I'm
like damn like this is weird it's so
different than [__] um then the bay
and I remember the first day I was
really walking I walked to Walgreens and
uh some dude drove by and called me a
SPI and threw a egg at me an egg yeah he
just had an egg he had a he didn't hit
me but he threw a egg at me it's not a
funny situation but it's funny when you
said it like that I'm like damn bro
first day heau me a SPI I'm like what
the [__] I'm like why are you calling me
a spck man he just had a egg that's the
craziest part about the story is like
bro I'm going to see a Mexican today I'm
going to P he had an egg bro you do it
at me that was my first experience of
Arizona before I even met my homies
before I even knew that there was hell
yeah oh not where you were living Bing
well I guess there was hella Mexicans in
the area I was living at it was just
that day some random [__] racist
bastard decided to pass by and throw a
[__] egg at me and say SP kind of
truck was it Trevor from GTA Trevor GTA
it's a [__] white truck dude I never
I knew it was a truck I already knew it
was a truck it was a white truck yeah
that's crazy how' your parents feel
about weed um you
know my dad was always like he was hella
blind like when I would come back and
visit in the bay like I would be getting
high in the apartment we lived in a
studio apartment it's probably like
nowhere it was way smaller than this
right here and there would be like a
little bathroom that we'd go into and I
pop the window and just smok my little
weed up my tin foil pipe and he never
smelted it he was hella blind to it my
mom she was like more like if you're
going to do it do it here cuz I grew up
fast like right when I got there sixth
grade started smoking weed right away
ran into hell of [__] in Arizona she was
like if you're going to do do here be
safe like don't [__] don't [__] around
and go get yourself caught up don't get
in trouble so my house was kind of like
the kickback spot M you know everyone's
got the homie course I was about to ask
say if you do it you hear oh so you can
drink at your house yeah yeah yeah my
homie that was right my house was like
the kickback house which is cool cuz she
wanted to keep me close it's cool but it
turns into I ain't going to school real
quick that's I mean for me I'm sure
we'll get into that right now question
you you know he smelled that right was
that you know he smelled that we cuz as
of now I used should box my grandma's
bathroom in the window and come out like
it's the steam no one's going to know
I'm a dumbass yeah the steam you smell
anything like I thought I was the
slickest fo ever out the window yeah
well mine was a can I it's it's an urban
myth I think the steam just makes you
feel better about the smoke in there but
either my dad was just blind as hell or
didn't give a [__] you know probably my
guess is he was probably just want his
kids happy and [__] you know are you
only child no I got I got u a brother
and then I got a step brother and two
step sisters oh [__] okay when you were
growing up San Francisco was like clean
nice or no no no San Francisco is always
been wild I mean it's not the way it is
it wasn't the way it is now with like
just like anyone could do anything they
want type [__] but it was definitely
always like I remember when I moved to
Arizona people tried to make fun of me
because I was from SF I was like cool
all right well you know I would D I
would pay you any amount of money to
last one day on this bus line from start
to finish like you guys think it's all
funny game like [__] you get
your ass raw beat up like SF is real and
I remember showing them like music like
JT the bigger figer 115 17 Reasons from
gold toes and them like showing them
like yo like the bay is really active
like here's three times crazy here's
this here's M Dre like y'all are
tripping dude like this [__] over here
is is cool and respect to y'all but you
guys see the bay is all just reron and
[__] Full House like forgot about
rice you just threw it back on me it's
full house and that's all I remember
when I was a kid but I I used to go uh
my mom would take me to
uh come on what's where Amie is at hey
Street there you go cuz my mom go all
the little hippie shops do all that
little pizzer with that nasty ass goat
cheese [__] I told you about yeah so my
experience in San Francisco was we're
dirt poor we're going to do what we can
for free walk around that was it so my
experience in San Francisco was a lot of
more bums and kids skateboarding and
[__] you know there was some crazy [__]
as a kid growing up in San Francisco it
was a very liberal City you see crazy
[__] you see the pride parades of people
just doing what you'd be like whoa what
the [__] is going on out here right but
you'd be you accept it and then you see
like people selling dope in the streets
you see [__] I remember vividly
being like in sixth grade coming back to
visit and going down to hate Street and
people being like nugs nugs they have a
butt on their forehead and I'm like damn
that's the hardest way like they' be
standing there they like nugs nugs nugs
and they pull it off and just to show
how fresh sticky it was I'm like damn
those dudes are savages I'm like I like
what's the forehead got you now yeah
sticky I've never heard about anybody
doing that my life that was big dude I
would just been like y look at this [__]
I'm
St straight plant it around their
forehead and talk to you and look at you
like damn that F got what you got dog
you know what I'm saying so I saw that
viral video of the dude like kind
filming the kids getting off the bus all
the Tweakers shooting up and [__] I
think it was like
a the that's wild it's like I don't know
to me you park your car next to
someone's house but they live outside MH
yeah I mean it is what it is it's like
La it's just San Francisco where I mean
you're from there but I'm so used to
going and going wow it's nice out here
oh there's a lot of bums but now it's
just like where's all the nice [__] it's
uh it's I mean if you know you know
there's areas you can go and kind of be
cool that
but there's like a lot of there's a lot
of like petty crime [__] happening right
now that just being kind of ignored it's
kind of sucks M it's kind of getting a
reputation of like somewhere you don't
even want to go like vacation to
downtown or leave your [__] at all I
mean we're doing a whole movie about
this [__] yeah that was one of our
questions yeah I watched the trailer
kind of a big part of yeah so what you
think about the quality and like
cinematically it looked beautiful yeah
like I'm a videographer so that's the
first thing I noticed when people put
out their own movies yeah he was just
telling me about it right now yeah yeah
I'm excited about it I mean as soon as I
get back to the Bay we're we're in full
production right now me the guys are at
my building right now looking at scripts
and deciding characters and locking down
locations and we're trying to get
permits and do it right because I guess
the city saw my trailer and was like oh
you're going to shoot a movie without
permission I'm like try to ask for
forgiveness but [__] oh so you put the
trailer together as like a concept to
then go make the movie yeah we shot we
shot a couple scenes and then like I did
it like the right way though I kind of
worked backwards I shot a couple
different scenes so I can make a a like
a trailer not not like a it's like more
like a teaser it's not the trailer cuz
the trailer would have like words and
that would be like a compilation of the
whole film The teaser was like almost
like a mood board kind of prove like
this is what it's going to look like
this is what it's going to feel like and
this is what it's going to be about M
can you give us what it's what it's
going to be about yeah so it's about
like a a crew of bippers you know some
Smash and grab um cats from the bay that
kind of like come up together and uh one
of their brothers plays ball and uh some
crazy [__] happens and it just kind of
like really kind of reflects like the
fast life can like catch up fast and
like there's repercussions for
everything you know type [__] so it's
about it's about the city it's about the
smash and grab culture it's about the
whole bit uh you know praise right now
it's about just some crazy Cutthroat
back door Bay Area [__] you know so it's
just it's a good it's a good story and a
lot of people like you're glorifying B
bipping you're doing this but they don't
really quite know that there's actually
really good script behind this film it's
not just U it's not just a film just
showing a bunch of people doing hella
crime it's like it's a really good story
I wrote it with my friend David and uh I
think I feel like um it's going to open
up a lot of eyes and it's going to
probably like open open up the door for
us in the film space is this your first
time being so involved in a project like
this yeah it's my first film you know I
have um developing a series right now
with FX [__] yeah I can't talk about
what or or you know who's involved but
it's a very big project cool
congratulations very very very very very
very big project and um that that should
start coming to life soon and so my
thoughts were like okay cool well if I'm
going to be in the building with someone
like FX and developing a show that's
going to be extremely powerful on the
film side things that I should probably
start getting into cuz I've always
wanted to do film like that's my passion
like weeds my hobby but my passion is
really like music and film and of course
I Love Weed otherwise I wouldn't be in
it still but I've always wanted to get
to a place where I could do film so for
real I thought it'd be yeah for sure so
I thought the first step should be doing
this film which is like a easy like it's
local could probably get done for under
a million bucks a million bucks maybe
one five and then from there kind of
move into like an urban Slasher get into
like a credit card scamming film then
get into like you know some other films
so I want to own my own portfolio work
on the film space as that show on FX
starts to pop off because if that show
actually really does what I think it's
going to do what I hope it does then if
I own a body of films then I could
probably get in the right doors actually
boom boom boom license Mount and stuff
like that so all right so hold on this
film besides weed movies and film is my
favorite thing on earth it's what I
think about all day every day same with
this guy right mhm I'm going to just
jump ahead I asked every guest I was
going to ask till later what's your
three favorite movies that aren't
comedies that are comedies that aren't
comedies oh that aren't comedies I mean
for sure Good Fellas uh for sure um
Blood In Blood Out um which is almost a
comedy it's the Mexican Good Fellas yes
uh and I feel like the third one have to
be it be a tie between [__] uh it's so
tough man it'd be a tie between three
it'd be a bronx tail Casino or or blow
cuz blow is the first movie ever made me
cry really yeah that made me that movie
made me want to sell weed yeah it made
me c walking through the hotel with his
daughter the scene with his daughter
[__] oh yeah yeah damn cuz I had my
little girl and I was trapped in the
time I was like damn man it's going to
be me man [__] I got I got to be good
man Dam you had kids young as [__] then
yeah you were what 17 when that movie
came out I was like I remember when it
came out I was in the ninth grade I
don't think I don't think it was when it
came out it kind of made me tear Jerk it
was like when my baby was like two and I
was watching at the crib one time like
damn that could be really be mean one
day if I don't get my [__] straight you
know you see everything different yeah
in those first couple years you're like
oh yeah you guys probably kids the same
age yeah but film was like film is
something that I'm really into and um
and I'm actually like in the writer room
for the other development uh the show is
being developed right now so it's like
I'm going to film school like I'm
learning like you know I'm learning so
good [__] dude yeah he's been doing all
the Super Bowl commercials and all that
[__] he's been doing like a lot of
cinematic stuff for a long time so he'll
just send me [__] off the bat I'm like
all right I'm learning [__] today I
guess Marty sends me wild [__] so when
it comes to cinematics like you I'm
sorry we see movie like Dam how much
that shot us holy [__] man like that
that that teaser we did but we thugged
it we pulled up we rendered a whip
that's a whip that got bipped and and
that teaser we we did that [__] in broad
daylight in public people like oh my God
like shut the fu hold on you rented it
you filming we're like we're filming
something like [__] cuz homie pulled up
like popped it everyone's like oh my God
[__] like no just chill it's all good D
got permit we did that we did that [__]
on the I told him I said bro you got one
chance to hit that [__] bro make
it look good he's like all right got it
all one shot well yeah you're in [__]
public see I I love hearing this cuz
there would be like the times like wait
for this lady to walk by all right let's
do this [__] real quick cuz there's no
permit there's I'm not paying you to do
we just we just did it the right way we
just did it how every real film is made
from the beginning like every real good
cult classic is like a it's like a like
a film like that that you just kind of
do gorilla you know what I'm saying like
it's not always like mapped out and big
big budget and we're going to block the
street off and get extras everywhere
like that's when you actually prove
your that's that's part three or four
for me I'm going to do the first couple
like kind of thugged out you know so we
just had a big actor in here he was
explaining like as much that you can do
yourself of this [__] he's like please
God do it yourself don't let them come
in and take it from you you do it well
the thing is like the buyer you know
I've been trying to write films for a
while and and every time I got to like
the Finish Line the buyer would want
something different and they was try
they try to delute your creativity and
like what you saying to me and so my
whole thing is like nah I'm I got money
I'm just going to do my own [__] and I'm
going bring the finished product to the
table the way it should be and hopefully
someone [__] with it yeah and if not
you just put it out yourself and it's n
[__] I'm going to go I'm going to pop
it off exctly we're independent dude
we're going to figure it out like I go
the way Taylor Swift did her [__]
partnering with AMC or whatever it was
and actually rolled her [__] out she
made she made 100 m dude off of what
she's doing like screenings like actual
she part I heard about this they're
playing her concert right yeah they they
filmed it but they released it like as a
film at all the movie theaters she
partnered with AMC or whatever it was
directly M so my whole thoughts are like
well before I even uh find a
distribution partner I'm probably going
to pick like 10 cities maybe five key
cities Arizona New Mexico New York York
the Bay La yeah maybe a couple other
ones Deb this [__] get lines down the
block do a recap of it submit it to a
couple film festivals and by the time
that all shakes out their perception of
like the the want for this film is going
to be out there into the world and
people going to have to find a way to
put it out [__] yeah yeah work backwards
yeah you're kind of forcing it out there
I mean [__] it's a good put the world
baby so when you get back your that's
when you start you're saying with
scripts characters and everything else
no scripts already done characters
already selected we already did
auditions we had 22 ,000
auditions shout out to everyone that
auditioned to this to this film it was
really hard 22,000 people yeah how many
rolles is that man it was like it's
probably like like 15 plus rolls but
like it just was a lot of people
interested man it's been tough bro
that's why the my partners were kind of
trolling me before I came here before we
started the interview there FaceTime man
this is our building now you ain't even
over here I'm like I'll be right there
but it takes a lot of work and you want
to you want to also involve like local
talent M but you want to get
professional actors too so you got to
try to please both worlds but we got a
good we got a good cast some really good
um some really actually really good
actors and some really good new Talent
we're about to introduce to the world
good [__] [__] sounds awesome it's like
yeah you know how to quarterback a
project I mean you've been you just
music for 18 years in hip-hop right over
goddamn 40 albums put out 50 I think
we're at 50 right now 50 four albums
yeah so yeah you know take a project
from A to Z and at least from my
perspective one thing I wanted to say as
a graphic artist like your commitment to
the cover art since the early days I
tapped in with that from the very
beginning I had I have some of your
cover art saved on my discs from 10 15
[__] years ago like I just wanted to
get your thoughts on that like the whole
prohibition series the hempire [__] like
going back all those different things
like just the look of it has there been
your Creative Vision from the start C
artist work yeah 100% I mean me and my
guy shm shout out to photo doctor he's
done like 95% of my covers yeah maybe 98
actually oh damn uh so we always have a
theme we we'll come up with the title
we'll think of the theme like I just
started a project last night cuz I was
bored and didn't have anything to do
when I when I got done with our
interviews for the new cookies Melrose
and um oh yeah you said that because
you're dropping it when does that come
out uh probably I Dro this new album no
no no the store oh store uh February
10th I think okay that's but uh point is
I got in there last night started making
this [__] I was like I want to call it
the farmers market called shm I'm like
look dude come to the compound we'll set
up like a little sick ass table can me
like on some hippie [__] like at the
booth you know we'll go to Marine
Farmers Market kind of like put
ourselves in the middle and so we come
up with Concepts we start tweaking on it
and that's why you see like the multiple
image roll out sometimes like like an
image like a teaser image and another
one boom see the cover boom yeah love
that yeah so photo doctor is the best at
that it's cut from the mixtape era it's
kind of a little bit lost today I grew
up on Match yeah it is MHM yeah people
understand like music good music is
great but like a full package is is even
greater if you're going to come out with
like a good title and a good track list
and you're going to come out with like a
good like packaging and you know good
videos like it's all it all makes
everything's that much bigger and makes
it last longer and ex kind of sticks to
people more you know MH yeah exactly not
to jump around it years and [__] there
was some I needed to ask it's going to
be a throwback I don't want to cut you
off but I just want to wait till you
guys got that music part out yeah you
have a good memory obviously you
remember someone call you spck and throw
egg at you mhm what's the first sack you
ever sold in your life first sack I ever
sold the first sack you ever sold on
your own not with your homies not
breaking off on my uncle like I'm trying
to think of everything that I ever did
like no you got to remember the first
one because sometimes when you're
looking at a grow room and you're like
damn we're doing all this I remember
when I used to burn plastic bags and
shut it for a t sack like there's got to
be that one I ask every everybody I know
Benny Benny we asked Benny the same [__]
let me take a second and think it was
definitely in Arizona oh so you got bad
over there yeah no all my all my homeboy
um when I was in sixth sixth grade like
all my homeboy big brothers were selling
bails brick weed
oh the first time so the first time I
actually seen weed was with my homeboys
we smoked in the backyard but when I
first time I seen it before we smoked it
we walked in the room there's bails
everywhere and they like opened up
plastic and pulled like a piece of brick
off and went to their bathroom and turn
on the shower and this team kind of came
and this little brick went
like I kind of expanded and we rolled it
up in in a receipt paper when we got
high and receip paper I think the first
thing we did was you know play with weed
we start chewing it to see if it get
aside yeah the stck we're trying to [__]
with it but the the first time I sold it
I feel like was probably at school in
sixth grade I remember I had a little
extra left I think it was probably like
I think about like a little over a half
ounce I sold some kid named Dustin
that's a lot your first damn but of
brick weed so no matter what it you feel
like the [__] man right now I feel
like the man when I came to when I came
to visit my pops and SF and stay with
them and I went to go see my friends
from fifth grade and I was all in this
[__] weed head [__] they're like whoa
like they're so all innocent and [__]
like I'm like what the [__] but
connected with their big brothers and
seeing bombass weed for the first time
California weed yeah and smoked it I
remember watching B it about it by
Master P yeah and laughing my ass off my
boys what's so funny I'm like this is
the worst movie I've ever seen in my
life but it's great I was high as [__]
bringing that weed back I took seven T
sacks put it in the sock put in my
[__] Let IT hand from hang from my
pant leg back to Arizona when I brought
that [__] back to
a that's when I felt like the man cuz
that's something that no one's ever seen
before no one's ever tasted before all
the big brothers that we were taking
weed from were like oh [__] what's up
with this I'm like ooh yeah San
Francisco right yeah y'all was making
fun of yeah I was what was I I was this
I was that all right cool what's up with
this little bag right here4 for 10 yeah
so you know 3 50 on the East Coast we
called kind of shitty weed Zona like I
don't know if that like got that name I
never [__] with this shitty we I was
very lucky oh a couple times but I was
very lucky you know it was weird cuz
then you go back to the bay and there
would be no shitty weed like Dolores
Park is the only place you can get some
like mid at or downtown you know they
have like the two for eight like a
little 10 sacks a bammer but you know
the Bay Area is just full with good weed
so I think the first time I really ever
felt like the man with weed was when I
brought it back from a brought it back
from De Bay to a and showed off that
[__] my boys were like damn fool cuz no
one believed me when I went to
California they didn't believe that my
boys had big old like dude you know how
much this [__] cost all right whatever I
didn't understand there's a big
difference and then when I went back to
Arizona and I started telling people I
got some [__] that's $20 a grand like
what it's like $20 an ounce out here
dude like what are you talking about I'm
like dude it's totally different so
being able to kind of educate people is
kind of fun too dude I just I remember
doing that the first thing I got [__]
champagne bro it's fire it it was mid-
graded outdoor at the best it just had a
smell well Sam sold me a zip I remember
ninth 10th grade so yeah I made 10 sacks
dashing around school so that feeling
but I'm just imagining you tell me if
I'm right fully wearing Mark Ekko
selling little 10x yeah am I right
n it was it was NAA NAA okay okay NAA
man I was in NAA and what else was
popping back I was rocking natica in
some Cool Water cologne for sure what
sling slanging big big Mexican weed in
Arizona and then transporting Little T
sacks from from the bay to to a and I
think I think the most I got away with
getting was the QP and that was like the
most dangerous uh like my film I wrote
that before I I wrote this film maybe
like eight years ago and it was ba based
you know on something I'm working on now
but like the opening scene was that was
that moment where I kind of took the
same sock method but this time I put the
Zips and I was so caught up in like
movie Life I'm thinking I'm in [__]
belly I took these sandwich bags and
wrapped them with cellophane and for
Vaseline and I'm [__] dumbass bro
dumb ass dumb ass work I'll tell you why
so I'm sitting there wrapping up you
know Zips making them all [__] solid
and [__] wrapping up with [__]
Vaseline and cellophan cuz I was
watching [__] belly thinking I was
about to do something and uh put that
[__] in a long sock had it hanging from
my pants and I'm standing there and
lying and I'm
like oh [__] no I'm like oh [__] I go
through TSA and this is before TSA was
really a thing this is pre 911 get
through my little you know little thing
get on the plane and I sit down and I
never forget that smell when I sat down
I was like oh my [__] going to jail
I'm going to jail I'm [__] I got a QP
in my [__] pants and this [__] smells
insane I'm talking about that Vaseline
intensified that weed dude like that
[__] A do [__] a matter of fact by me
squeezing it hell much opened it up it
opened up that CH hella much I didn't
know about I was a kid yeah squeeze it
down Tighter and I remember getting off
the plane and walking up to my homeboy
uh my homeboy cousin's brown Cadillac
and I walked up he said damn fool you're
hot as [__] I'm like I know dude get the
[__] out of here and I remember pulling
that sock out and holding it up like
dude you're crazy we pulled up at the
gas station got a swisher rolled up to
the Moon baby I had a QP and a it was
over Honestly though I I kind of missed
those days that a swisser and a car ride
was the fun of the day cuz cuz now it's
like no roll up like a zip Z Let's get
high [__] I kind of missed that that I
didn't realize you're going through TSA
now that makes sense I didn't realize
you hear this [__] I've been through TSA
so many times as a kid cuz blow remember
he's walking through who has Coke in his
false bottoms he's walking through in
Black B he's playing I thought that was
the coolest [__] I was 13 years old what
happens I go to Oregon CU my dad moved
here I am putting Zips in in in American
Beauty double cassette VHS case I got
searched they flagged me searched me
didn't find it I'm sitting there just
like should I run like I'm in a federal
billing where you running to and twice I
got searched so here and that you're way
worse than me I would have never put it
on me that's [__] crazy the rule is
you got to keep it on you cuz I'm afraid
to get hit later I'd rather know right
now talk more that's wow my rule is I'm
not ever going to have it on me so I can
deny no my my whole little game was like
if I'm if I'm get hit I want to know
right now I want to know right now if
I'm going to get hit let let me just
know right now and and um that's the way
I always did
it wow I came with a different meod
completely I remember going to Arizona
one time I had some [__] on me that I
was not supposed to have just put like
that I remember walking up to his
security line I've never told this story
at all at all ever I remember seeing
that first time they had that little
thing you step in body
scan oh my [__] I was like I'm oh my God
I'm already in line like dude what the
[__] is this thing like what is this
yeah I even know what it
is I don't even think I'm actually ready
to tell what happened but I did
something very crazy and it worked and
swallowed it
[Laughter]
no
no no I didn't I've seen too many horror
stories about that I've seen seen too
many horror stories about only one
option yo you have to do how old were
you though bro I was like 16 exactly
you're 16 I was 14 I'm like my life is
done I'll run first and eat this [__] it
was uh that suck I I just remember being
in that thing when it spun around me I'm
like how is I'm going to tell my mom
this [__] dud how am I going to tell my
mom this [__] if this goes down and I
remember them letting me out and walking
away and like well that [__] don't work
oh the thing yeah that [__] don't work
that was crazy wow Jesus Christ yo
you're risking it I didn't know I didn't
know there was other kids doing this
[__] I have hell stories going through
the airport bro I ke I keered a half zip
of coke dude a half zip and I'm not
talking about like inside keer hold it
just put it between like here I am I'm
flying a I'm flying a man my boy like yo
bring me some of that [__] your homeboy
got cuz Arizona was like a Coke Hub but
it was like dirty like dirty cartel Coke
right and
my boy who I was getting all the crazy
ass weed from has some crazy ass [__]
they called it Mr Mister I don't do Coke
I'm not promoting Coke or anything like
that but at the time I did what I had to
do to get money this [__] was like pink
tint it was insane so I was like bro for
the dude and his he he wanted that
baller [__] I'm like I'm going to bring
you something it's all good got a half
ounce of coke in my pocket I'm in line
I'm like what the [__] is that I see his
lady go through and like put your hands
above your head I'm like oh [__]
like I'm [__] going to jail I'm like
I can't get out of line I took
it right between I'm like I'm not going
to push it in cuz I'm not going to do
that I'm just going to keep it hope it
doesn't fall out one and two hope I
don't [__] get [__] caught with
this [__] so I have to explain this to
world and three I don't know if it's
going to I don't know if it's going to
open up or what D like I got through man
I got through and had to go to the
bathroom on Southwest and take it out
man this [__] Shady bro remember giving
this to my homeboy yo bro I went through
some [__] to get in
here sh don't even know man he touched
some shady bag man ain't getting no sick
but yeah man get sick of you know the
air the airport man the airport was not
my friend you know and then I went
through a time with airports where like
I went through a time with airports
where bro [__] they would pull me off
the plane bro like you have to remember
I started working at the hemp Center 18
and I would travel places with the owner
and I remember coming back from
Amsterdam and some guy like an um like a
Hawaii style shirt like kind of opened
up button up I was like hey come here
real quick I'm like uh for what he's
like
dea and they're like we want to ask you
some questions and they searched my bags
and they help me for like an hour or so
and asked me a lot of weird personal
questions and he was like my name is
Jesus just call me God cuz I know
everything about you I'm like well um
Jesus I'm like that's a hard ass line
I'm sorry that's hard I hit him back
with a harder line I said on I said well
if you're Jes Jesus and why are you
asking me questions damn it just had
that well you are a rapper you write
some good [__] okay I'm like if you a
good line right there bro why are you
asking me questions but I went through a
whole stage of airports where bro I
wouldn't fly into LAX um I B barely
recently started flying to LA because La
gave me just severe PTSD the feds even
later in my life so that started 18 so
yeah so hold on
18 in the airport and they say hey da
we're coming back from Amsterdam you
know they asked me what I was doing in
Amsterdam they asked me what I you know
if I brought money out there if I
brought back seeds they were looking all
through my [__] they asked me about my
owner of the dispensary I worked at they
asked me about people I was actually
really [__] with at the time I'm like
what the [__] is this [__] like are you
serious [__] no they knew [__] but you
know um than sir I feel like I feel like
when I came back from Jamaica they
started getting real I was still 18 I
flew to Jamaica that's when it started
getting real funny with me why you
traveling with the owner over here why
you going over here why you doing this
why you doing that like what you guys
got going on you guys hiding money like
Jamaica's a big drug Hub like they made
they made me missed my flight so I'm
like I'm never I'm I'm cool out this
[__] and that happened when I was like
18 it [__] with my head a little bit
then later on in life like right like
around like The White Album days and
[__] like that they start [__] with
me big time put hey you got some money
on you man yeah come here what are you
doing in Atlanta you know how do you
know this person how you know this
person can we search your bags and they
[__] with me every time uh at LAX every
time I get off the flight from like
Atlanta from Houston from whatever I was
doing cuz I was actually really going
out there to do music remember the
yokona video the what the Yoko video
with whiz big crit and Chris Brown I
mean no not specifically so I did a
video in Atlanta uh with whiz Chris
Brown big crit [__] was huge bro like it
was sick launch on World Star H remember
that lach on World Star lach on World
Star H milons if views start going crazy
I get off the plane I'm so high on like
releasing this video and doing this play
in the a remember getting off the plane
so's like hey uh can I holl at you quick
I'm like yeah you want a picture he's
like
no not this [__] again what the [__]
friendly all you sound like they're
friendly hey come here they're nice uh
and uh they they pull me aside in front
of everybody they don't take you to a
back room they pull me aside in front of
everybody and they start going through
my [__] and asking me how the questions
are there yeah right there in LAX so you
know that [__] kind of traumatized me
man airports I've been through a lot in
airports but I'm just glad that by the
time they started really [__] with me
I was just on this this clear path of
just like being a weed entrepreneur and
and a rap cat like they they thought I
was doing something other than what I
was really doing and they were just on
my ass about it and talked to my lawyers
when I lowered up they're like oh they
think you're a money mu they think
you're flying money back and forth for
people I'm like that's [__] funny not
so you know but I'm just grateful that
the days of me bringing COC [__] when
I was 16 or the days of me bringing QPS
I never got caught up it's like I took
that big risk as a kid but then later on
in life they just started assuming I'm
this like crazy like mule for somebody
or something I'm like you guys got it
all [__] up mhm yeah way scarier way
scarier than it needs to be bro yes 18
years old no I feel you cuz I mean every
time I go to airports I'm like Dam I
remember this but I don't have that hey
come here I never I don't think I ever
risked it enough to go so that was one
of my questions was was that's how you
started you started working in the
dispensary when you were young right
yeah I started working I was 18 doing
what though uh I started with intake
butt tending and then worked my way up
to like buyer manager running the store
pretty fast though like within like a
year but you know when I I've been some
since I was in sixth grade so it was
just natural to me and you know I
started off shooting a documentary there
which is is why I got hired I would pull
up and like bring my camera and
interview patients like kick it there
smoke at the lounge and she was like you
just want to work here don't you I'm
like I would love to work here it's like
cool you're hired so that's how I got
hired there that's so [__] awesome I
just wanted to ask that because there's
a lot of people out there go yo how do I
like do [__] I love what I love seeing
this online like you guys are doing this
you're in your own your own business
you're doing that you're making videos
you're making
music thank you I always say just get a
[__] butt tender job go go mop people
people ask me for advice all the time
and uh they're like how do I get in the
game how do I get in position I'm like
bro I started off from the bottom and I
just learned like a sponge and I app
appli my energy and everything I learned
and just kept going and I just never
stopped that's how you get in you got to
get in from the bottom yo what's up guys
taking a moment to talk about one of our
sponsors and this is my bookie stop what
you're doing if you like gambling right
now and you're already signed up for my
bookie make your homie sign up for my
bookie right now and once you do use
code dope as usual get $200 free cash
bonus then go to your other friend's
phone and make them do it and then make
them do it and then now you got 800 free
cash bonus for signing up using Code
dope as usual football season's nearly
over but don't forget go to the live
casino remember last time we actually
hit on our first time ever betting $3600
off the bat what you're going to want to
do is download my bookie app sign up use
code dope as usual and go bet those 200
cash free bonus go bet on Blackjack go
bet on poker or go bet on your favorite
team for next week or go bet on baseball
go bet on do whatever you want my bookie
has every single thing every single
Sport and a live casino and like I said
go make five of your friends go sign up
right now use code dope as usual bet it
all on black Dolphins bills Jets
Patriots whoever your team is whoever
your favorite team the playoffs are here
get bet and get started with my bookie
so you start with a bun teder I got to
be honest it's kind of funny to hear
that you're you're over there
interviewing you're kind of like a weed
a weed tuber back before that [__] was
even real yeah yeah and now correct me
if I'm wrong I mean you've scaled you
sced is up
to 50 60 locations now across the world
uh I think we have 70 70 stores 70
stores [__] and we're talking about 12
years maybe since going from it you kind
of branding it as a strain to being the
brand that it is now honestly like
cookies kind of started back in like 200
maybe like 11 or 12ish or something like
that you know you had my friend in San
Jose kind of pushing the brand first he
he put cookies logo on the wall and
sound Ed kind of got it popping before
before it was actually like a real
company that's when we just had our
genetics kind of doing our thing in
garages and SF and whatnot and then you
had the connected group kind of licensed
some genetics and kind of use my name to
kind of get it popping back in the days
I think you did some work with them yeah
with Luke and everybody that was like a
like a learning phase for me to
understand like okay these guys are
raising money they're kind of doing
their thing they're really benefiting
from cookies I am too but like think I
could probably do a little better I
think I actually really do my thing with
this and so from the day that went wreck
we opened up I think like two weeks
after in Maywood that was our first
store so we went wck in when 2017 or
something like that so 70 stores since
then 70 stores since 2017 10 stores a
year basically seven years I think we
did 20 in 2023 we 20 20 stores in 2023
damn and what was it Bangkok
yeah yo that's wild as sell that it just
goes legal out there you you already got
your store popping out there popping do
that [__] was wild like to see people
from all over the world pull up and like
be so excited like Asia is so excited
about weed man like I was going to
stores before a store opened up just to
kind of feel the vibe and I would see
people from China this just smells crazy
what is that by the way that's uh that's
some [__] from the powers up line uh
it's uh Siri Alam mode time Sher
Z Alam mode yeah time sh this is the one
I I was kind of like hesitating to gift
you today cuz I really want to just fly
back with it but after all our flight
stories I don't think I'm going to do
that I appreciate it that shit's insane
bro it's uh it's one of the best new
ones coming out R&D uh it's [__]
amazing I kind of P it smells like a it
smells like you remember when we were
kids the Push Pops you push them from
the bottom they hella hard with that
stick smell like the purple ones you
have to smoke one of these d i I was
like having Riders Block in the studio
last night and I rolled one of these and
I banged out [__] record hella fast I
was like cool hell yeah shout out to the
weed dude shout out to the weed so damn
it's a good one right here so to scale
so many locations in like inside a year
is that insanely stressful or do you
feel like you have it down now to the
point that you can like efficiently do
that it's stressful for a couple reasons
I mean anyone doing that kind of volume
is oh that's just extra oh it's extra
that's just extra okay cool I don't want
to [__] nothing you're good you're good
um it's stressful in a sense that like
for our business model we have to manage
a lot of different partners and like
deal with a lot of different
relationships are you franchising it no
no you can't and not anyone could just
open up a store that's what I was asking
yeah it's like um it's not franchise
because not anyone could open it up you
can't pay to do it we kind of just go
market by market and find the best
operator so let's just say yeah West
Virginia for example you you live in
West Virginia you cultivate good weed
that looks like this you're doing good
things on your own you have a store
right we would probably approach you and
and and say hey does it make sense for
you to get some new genetics in your in
your catalog does it make sense to paint
your building blue to give us a very
small royalty off it and maybe get the
purchase option in the future and we do
deals like that so it's not really like
a franchise thing it's more of a
partnership we get a chance to kind of
cherry pick our Partnerships in markets
like Florida you have to go vertical you
have to grow your own [__] and do your
own thing because you you can't just
like do you have to do it yourself all
the way from bottom to top so that's an
exception but like markets like you mean
like legally yeah mhm yeah yeah so
everything has to be in housee yeah
everything like in States like uh you
know let's just say like uh Colorado was
like that for a while right color no
Colorado you could work with different
people like cuz Colorado you can have
people cultivate for you you can you
could do licensing deals like that so
okay but Florida was like n you have to
buy a license there limited license
market and a lot of these markets are
limited license but they allow you to do
things like that like in Arkansas we
have a good partner out there and
they're one of the only groups of like
good cultivation and storefronts popping
off like it'd be way too hard for us to
open or to enter a limited licensed
market like that on our own just it's
tough yeah and if you want to expand
fast and you should probably take
advantage of the fact that there's
people that would love to work with you
network with you and it's actually
pretty cool because we have a bunch of
relationships around the world off with
people that sell weed and that grow weed
and that's why I've been doing my whole
life anyway so our business model was a
little different it was like we don't
want to raise hundreds of millions of
dollars and lose control of what the
brand looks like and feels like and is
we'd rather go partner with people
people that like what we do that that
appreciate what we do and that would
like to amplify what we do and we can
amplify them because if you look at one
of our models like a store operator that
would change to a cookie store they keep
like 95% of their bread we only take 5%
royalty so it's very beneficial to them
if if it ever goes Federal then we'll
decide whether we want to roll up those
assets or not but like it's a very good
lucrative model we get to expand and
they get a chance to get a huge boost
and [__] keep majority of the bread
and we all kind of all win like that you
know what I'm saying but it's stressful
going back to your question because it's
a lot of people to kind of manage and
it's a lot of personalities and has that
ever been done before like that I don't
think so no well I mean I don't think
there's any other store that has that
many stores I think I think we have the
most stores that even out of like the
companies that raise like $500 million
2002 billion doar like we're kind of
like I can't think of anybody else has
many stores kind we're kind of doing it
right now Jesus Christ it had to be so
insane to see the New York City One go
up crazy that one's about to open up
soon we're just waiting on like the
final license but we're going to
actually sell Wei there soon it was just
clothing there oh oh it's open to The
Dispensary now do you do you sell the
clothes in the dispensers or it's always
adjacent like next to it no like we
certain stores we we always have like
some good printables in there and [__]
like that so yeah we we definitely sell
like we call it cookies local Reserve so
like each store will have like their own
[__] got you okay okay question so
you're talking about all these stores
and the Partnerships I got to ask why on
Earth leg legitimate question why did
you open a store in Merced California
man I love the valley I I love the
valley I mean but you know what I'm
saying
Merced come on man I'm born and raised
in Merced I saw went what we have weed
stores and now a Cookie Shop bro you
know the valley is always giving me more
love than you know anywhere else in the
world you know like for shows and of
course like they always love the music
so much I'm like dude these people are
going to back me if I come out here
they're going to be excited because I
know they appreciate Us coming out here
and I just I wanted to do it you know
when the opportunity came I'm like [__]
yeah we want to do that you know um yeah
that's just crazy D I pass by all the
time like Bo right there I mean you see
the whole town from the freeway you can
see both sides actually like oh that
one's nicer as a as a stoner think about
this like we all love the weed right I
like to call myself a vertically
integrated Stoner right that that's was
the cool part about all this [__] to me
I got my own papers I got my own grinder
company I got my own weed company I got
everything I partner with big lighter
like there's a lot of cool [__] going on
right now right and I like I think it's
cool like if I were to drive from the
bay I could stop in mered grab a sack
you know Smoke on the whip look look
Smoke on the whip get to Fresno right
get another sack pull up to Kinga have a
[__] kick back in my lounge and get
to La very comfortable it's like then I
get to La I have stores here I have all
these being grown here in LA it's like
at land in Detroit Fresh off the plane
our cultivation partner like bro here's
all the new [__] I'm like damn I'm
smoking doggy bag in Detroit dog [__]
land in [__] Thailand get to see our
gentics being [__] grown there like
it's cool to actually land and not have
to think about the things we had to do
as a kid to get it there that's I'm
about to say you're skipping the airport
scared it's it's full circle for me bro
I'm like damn this shit's actually
pretty cool no what you just said sounds
like the best road trip I remember the
beta La Road Trips I mean take packs to
Beta La when like you got cookies you
got GSC you got platinums I mean
remember those were like 45 a p and I I
can only imagine being able to stop at
my own store in mered and then my own
store in F what you just said right now
what made me feel just it's just tight
bro it's even cool seeing even if you
don't have time to stop you're like boom
I'm here I'm here boom I get to La I'm
all through this [__] cool boom landed
Oakland oh our storees right there cross
the bridge of SF oh we're right over
there like I seen a map recently of all
the states were in that [__] blew my
mind I'm like damn damn bro this shit's
real dude this shit's actually really
real and a lot of people you know we get
we get kind of like um we get [__] you
hear bro we're all in the community
people say cookies went corporate
cookies did this bro like I didn't set
out to compete with with like Street
Brands I didn't set out to compete with
my fellow like Trappers I didn't do that
I set out to shake [__] up to the bigger
msos that were like making weed whack
when it got legal a bunch of investment
Bakers a bunch of real estate people got
in the game they didn't care about
genetics they didn't care about anything
and if you really think about the grand
scheme of things I'm going state to
state where there's limited licenses
where people could do whatever they want
meaning they can grow trash and I hire
people that's not from the culture to
run things I go ahead I make a move and
I have people start growing real
genetics operating stores of people that
look like us and feel like us right it
makes people do what care well it makes
them have to do the same and compete so
I was thought they me the customer like
I would care about that no the customers
care but now these other MS that were
growing trash ass weed doing trash ass
[__] business there like cookies is
here they're growing good weed well they
got [__] a vibrant store they're
doing things for the culture we got to
do the same and so people aren't looking
at the bigger picture when our kids are
older either is either going to be dope
or it's going to be whack and so I've
taken a lot of hits on the chin to kind
of get cookies where it's at and people
haven't really looked at the bigger
picture like I'm not sitting there
trying to make Hellas I don't even know
if that will ever happen I'm just trying
to make it to where when our kids grow
up there's good weed around there's
people that care about genetics there's
people that care about flavors some of
these aren't the best yielders but they
taste great and I think we're all in it
for the taste the high the experience we
love Bud like we love bud and we know
that we have to check certain boxes as
Bud dealers so you know at the end of
the day I feel like people can kind of
look at cookies and say we went
corporate no I got organized I got sick
of people Tak advantage of what I was
building and not understanding how to
monetize it properly I found people that
went to school for this [__] kind of G G
me up I still have full control of the
brand I still have the vision in my
hands I still have you know the look and
feel the the menu in my hands and I
think the most important thing is like
we're actually shaking [__] up for the
rest of us if you're a breeder if you're
a [__] cultivator if you're a [__]
brand and you want to go get into other
markets we're making it possible for
those conversations to happen because
we're shaking up [__] for our
competition our competition is looking
for guys like people watching right now
saying how can we kind of get at burner
how can we kind of how can we get next
to what he's doing and kind of like you
know kind of compete right they're going
to go hire California cultivators
they're going to go hire good
cultivators they're going to go hire
good breeders are going to go find
people from the culture to do marketing
to do social media I'm just trying to
help all of us get in position so the
shit's not whack because I do shop with
other people I do smoke other herb like
I enjoyed the hell out that joint I
don't even know what it was I'm probably
going to ask for a jar before I leave
like I'm actual we real weed head and so
like I just want to see people in
position around the world like I don't
want this [__] to be whack by the time
our time comes like I don't want this
[__] to be whack I never thought about
it that way I got to be honest because
look it you know better than anyone I I
don't really know about we coners I
don't really know about like genetics
and this and this my homie John over
here he he tells me about [__] I I I
don't I don't know because I don't grow
weed man like I smoke weed I buy weed
I'm happy as [__] I'm not trying to get
into like who said what I don't know
it's really cutro but you know I think
that things have changed since it went
wreck like when it was medical [__] was
player bro everyone was working together
it was so much more fun we was a ride
around with bags and do our thing and
get pulled over and say we're a vendors
we're about to go to Club and everyone
was happy making money and no one was
Cutthroat coming at each other but as
soon as it went wreck and people with
money starting getting involved with
people from the streets and people from
the game started putting in their mind
what they think business should look and
feel like it started creating this like
weird
competitive culture and it's like this
whole like weird ass vibr right now in
cannabis and this shit's whack like I
just really just want to tell people
like stop like focus on where we're at
right now we all used to do this [__] in
in a whole different way we have to
adapt with change if you want to be in
the game it's kind of saturated right
now it's kind of tough but like don't
let people that's not from our industry
influence you on the moves you make in
business like just do what you do be
dope be good be consistent come with
heat and everything will play out but
like there's this weird attitude and
weed right now and the controversy's
gotten really bad ever since wreck
before wreck it was amazing there's like
little weed beef and [__] like that of
course there's always beef but not like
it is now see that's the thing like I
wish somebody would make a doc I don't I
don't know I just remember [__] from
clip like damn that F punched him we
need like trap Ross toak like trap Ross
exactly but of the weed industry cuz I
got to be honest man a lot of the things
you just I don't really know about the
controversy behind them like you're
saying cookies went corporate as in
people say that cookies is a corporate
company now but you were always a
corporation well I I think it's like our
people are so designed to think that
like doing the right thing and actually
growing is wrong oh [__] what is that
what did you just roll this one yeah you
smell that right right away I feel like
our people are designed to think that
like doing things organized or doing
things with purpose or like they just
look at like bad like I didn't go
corporate [__] I'm in business
like what do you want me to stay in a
certain level you want me to be like in
the Box you want the point the point
point is like to build something
powerful and you know you have to in
order build something powerful you need
a team and I'm not going to act like I'm
an accountant like I'm a a a Biz Dev guy
I'm not going to act like I'm a you know
marketing I'm just good at what I do and
I'm just going to do what I do and I
have other people compliment it to grow
it yeah it'd be like if someone says
Yola man [__] popping on Spotify
right now man what happened when you
just [__] doing your [__] on you like
Hey
brother don't you want to see my growth
isn't it amazing that we started this
from the bottom and now I have my own
studio and now I I'm actually being
highlighted by people like Spotify which
is big companies that actually recognize
but that's what it's all about exactly
so people like to talk [__] because
we're we're very hardworking
[__] like we're consistent I
didn't realize that's what you meant oh
that's that's just people being
[__] yeah oh yeah I get that [__]
all the time okay never mind like you
would never yeah get a studio like [__]
I was broke I can [__] get a studio
we're doing this yeah you want just to
like just do this for [__] for
nothing so so I understand what you're
saying that that's what you mean by
corporate who cares one hold on I'm
going to forget if I don't say it
now that is you that rolled a joint on
the the cover of traffic
yeah cuz I had that I'm like
that's did cuz I always looked at him
like one of his homies made fun of that
joint because I roll ugly ass joints
sometimes this fo will talk [__] cuz I
remember the my he chose it for the
cover huh you know what who cares if I
roll ugly joints sometimes I saw that
one like that's definitely you roll down
the traffic look at the end of the day
bro like you can roll I can roll like
the perfectly thin joint I could roll
like the the even joint but I like a
real a real grumpy weed smoke boss joint
like this is a boss Jo get pregnant at
the end I think I just fit like probably
like two or three grams in that [__]
that [__] heavy smoking you know
no I feel cuz I roll them they always
get and they get lumpy on one side like
oh you can't roll you smoke weave for a
living like I'm sorry I today I tried I
was like we'll be on camera I'm going to
try it's still [__] up okay feel
better no here's the thing like I roll
ugly ass joints no me and whiz go back
and forth we we have different styles
like I'll roll sometimes all the way
through with no tip so it'll be all weed
all the and it'll be consistent all the
way through just or I'll roll them like
small and grumpy and lazy like I'll take
one and quarters and just roll up hell
little joint or or like double fatties
where they're all fat we just have
different styles and like to [__] around
but I I think I can I think I can get
into joint rolling contest for different
styles [__] like that yeah but who could
fit the most in here I think I can can
do great on that it might be ugly though
might be overlapped and not even at the
end for sure I mean it's it's funny to
watch people like get a big ass joint
and get scared you know yeah and I and
Kenny power says I roll Loosey gooes I
roll them kind of loose so it's kind of
like I roll them loose and then I pack
them down cuz I don't like that Airy
Airy light feeling in my joints I like
to have them like a like I like it this
[__] is hitting someone someone
that doesn't really smoke hit this joint
they'd be [__] done be done yeah
people we have guest through you hand
them these [__] giant cannons and
they're all scared and [__] like oh mo
most most guests just don't yeah they
just don't hit it but it's okay it's
fine like it's not you don't have to get
high here yeah I mean some people can't
compose themselves on high you know
that's fine how much is like Edibles dab
shrooms part of your life uh shrooms on
a micro do level I used to do [__] way
harder when I was like younger I do acid
shrooms and [__] like that but I'll do
micro do right now um maybe if I'm and
like in Hawaii or something I'll eat
like a you know couple grams of shrooms
or something like that and just enjoy a
little more but um Edibles I'm scared of
them I went to Hospital off Edibles no
wait Hospital legitimately or hospital
just too high no I went to a hospital
dude not like was in there but I was too
high for sure but I think I had a reason
for it when did this happen man when I
found out my my girl was pregnant with
my first daughter oh so you were young
yeah I was working at the hemp Center oh
I was say if I could imagine being a
nurse guys too high come is that [__]
burner man bro kidding me I was at the
Hem Center bro and I we used to eat
Edibles like it was nothing cuz people
would bring things eat banana bread have
a raspberry bomber drink a [__] weed
tea oh here's some weed Twix bar let's
eat it and I was eating Edibles all day
and smoking all day and I got in the car
and we're driving and we're just like
looking out the window we're getting on
the bridge and she's like I'm pregnant
I'm like
what what I was like oh [__] and I
started thinking about it then I felt
I'm like what the [__] is that like the
[__] is this I started thinking you're
GNA die you're single I'm like die like
oh [__] I'm like pull over man go to
[__] hospital I think I'm dying she
like what do you mean I'm like I think
I'm dying and I didn't understand it at
first and I got to the hospital like no
you're good man your heart's just being
hella hard cuz you're on
[__] how many Edibles I'm like I
think I had like five or six days like
you're tripping dude and I think it was
cuz I actually really had to think about
something real and serious I like kind
of get out my comfortable the most
serious news you've probably ever gotten
at that moment the ongoing theme is big
news in cars with you so far yeah your
dad not your daughter
Jesus yeah man and uh I've seen multiple
rappers after that like just go downhill
with Edibles um I've taken multiple
famous people to the hospital for
Edibles oh people probably try to like
show out and course they do well they
would they would come to the store and
ask for Edibles they like yo let me get
like banana bread let me get a brownie
it looks good yeah and it's like
delicious that's a problem too yeah so I
had to take multiple people and after I
was like you know what I'm just not
doing Edibles anymore I probably could
be fine now but that day just kind of
turned me off a little bit no so you
haven't done edil since you were younger
N I smoke a lot of hash I like rosin um
I smoke like if I'm in a comfortable
setting like if I'm chilling if I know
I'm about to be somewhere then I get
high high start rolling up big worms and
taking like you know little dabs and
[__] like that um I'm not a hot nail guy
I hate hot dabs I do low temp no offense
if you took a hot one oh hell no he I
like them low I'm slow I like to taste
it and you know I got into Ros when I
got cancer so I was kind of like not
really ever into hash uh recently in the
recent years but in the beginning I was
into hash at the Hem Center they have
like like a bubble hash they'd have like
this thing called Amber ice I was on all
the blogs back in the days with whiz and
them we' be smoking this [__] it's like
shatter before shatter I feel like the
absolute s like the little see through
sh like Jurassic Park thing with a yeah
with the mosquito but like you know I
got into it more when I got cancer my
tolerance just got crazy cuz I was
smoking all day on chemo and [__] and I
was like I got to and and this was when
uh couple years couple years ago it's
been like two years yeah yeah I actually
I lost my father to the same type of
cancer yeah [__] scary brother what's um
any takeaways from kind of I don't know
if you'd say beating cancer but going up
against it and how you just maybe see
the world I feel like man like my
biggest takeway is that you cannot
stress over any little things anymore
like you have to be so blessed because
that [__] really almost came to an end
for your boy and had so many questions
when I was laying there trying to get
better I was like damn this going to
really get like this what about this
what if I never did this what if I never
did my films what if I didn't do this
and that so my whole thing is now like
we're hella blessed and a lot of things
that we find to be stressful really is
not that big of a the deal like it's
just really minimal you know like it's
like we're good bro and so I just kind
of like don't take anything for granted
anymore I'm super motivated at my second
shot like to see through things I've
always wanted to do like the film stuff
more documentary stuff um just more
different like I did live banded cookies
Christmas for the first time like that
was sick I've always wanted to do that
I'm like I have to do it now cuz I don't
want to not get the chance to do it so
I'm like let's get a live band and
[__] let's do it you know so I'm just
going taking like bigger leaps kind of
see things through you know but cancer
is real bro and um colon cancer is super
big especially for Latinos and blacks
right now I mean because the kind of
food that we grew up eating and [__]
like that so you know it's all based on
food and stress but mostly food mhm but
you're able to kind of it's in remission
now the treatment kind I'm good I'm two
years clean uh I actually just got a
test yesterday when I was doing my
interviews for cookies Melos I got the
negative uh negative test I got to take
one every three months for the next two
years m and they said if I make it past
two years of being clean if I'm like
four years clean then I should be good
MH at least for that one man they told
my dad he was in stage four he had to
like rush for emergency surgery and [__]
it was bad I lost my mom to stomach
cancer so I'm very familiar with that
[__] it was like full circle for me I'm
like damn [__] 38 man I'm about to go
out [__] it's [__] terrible but it
worked out in in my favor and I'm like
definitely never going to take that
blessing for granted cuz that shit's
what's your lifestyle change since then
diet for sure I lost about 50 lbs no
yeah you can see it and I just gain back
like 16 recently cuz my girl got
pregnant so the the mutual weight game
like I'll gain some for you I'll eat
this with you right now and then when
you're away I'll eat this for you
cuz but honestly biggest lifestyle
change is like no processed Meats no
sugary drinks
you know um I try to keep red meat down
as much as possible and I'm just trying
to keep like the amount of food intake
in as low as possible trying to stay
away from Candy and [__] always have
fruit on Deck you know have like some
good pineapple some good [__] sliced
mangoes or some [__] grapes sugar feeds
cancer right or a mushroom processed
Meats sugar and um sugar processed meats
and red meats Red meat's really bad I
love it though it's bad that's all I've
been craving since my GR was been
pregnant so he's vegan I'm vegetarian
for like ever so so that's a good step
and like I think that that that takes a
lot of concern out cuz like the red meat
kind of sticks and doesn't really kind
of get through but like another thing
you should always make sure you're kind
of being cautious on is like uh like
rice and bread and stuff like that
that's my favorite [__] in the world
that's my worst yeah me too it's I can't
I'm Mexican Italian I like bread and I
like
rice I like Asian food I love Asian food
oh I say do you like bad Asian food cuz
you're part Mexican yes I like I don't
know what it is about us I like hey
Asian food though I've graduated yeah no
no with time see and be like you would
have never ate that back then like bro I
didn't know about it see that's another
step like with food stuff like I'm
trying new stuff stuff I never tried
when I back it was like you know Pizza
burritos and a hamburger cuz I can
afford that [__] at McDonald's and the
fast food [__] [__] us food becoming
like a big business and trying to like
accommodate a lot of people at once is
what [__] us well it just became well
process but it's it's literally just not
even real at this point my new saying is
like if it's in a bag it's probably bad
you know like unless it's like some
unsalted cashews or some [__] like that
but like four years I did that yeah
don't drink nothing out of a bottle and
then I I messed up the past two and that
just that I could feel the difference of
just going a year going back to the no
no I I'm an
addict so four years clean and then I
messed up two years ago and I you know I
wanted he keeps driving try the
sparkling drink like I can't have it bro
I swear to God he tried on New Year's
like I can't drink that I will I'm an
I'm a drug addict and that's a drug like
that [__] is a drug I I I won't eat I'll
drink soda all dark sodas is if I'm
hungry [__] damn it's more
hearty and [__] yeah mug is the ultimate
one man with a little Bulldog on this
[__] Crush that [__] Pepsi Cherry Pepsis
I'll drink that [__] in the morning I
don't care so so all bad dude and
Mexicans just love that [__] love dude
[__] this guy right here drinks Cokes
all day oh man isn't it the best thing
on earth I used to do drugs and I will
drink a soda over doing a lme day carne
soda and Coke dude literally whether it
be Coca-Cola or cocaine dud dude no for
real Let's do let's C some [__] red
meat and drink a Coca-Cola and do a bump
when we're too drunk [__] get drunk
again no like subscrib Thursday through
Sunday yeah don't do that [__] leave it
alone put the blow down man it's t it's
bad though cuz you just subscribed to
everyone's life they're like hell yeah
like no bro no don't do it because I got
to be honest it's the vices but it's the
things that catch up and you're you're
literally looking at it going no you
can't you can't do this you can't do
this [__] what's what's your favorite
drug you've ever tried my favorite Dr
experimented too okay all right hold
on my favorite drug that I can just keep
doing all the time or My Favorite Drug
that's like oh that was the most fun
I've ever had like someone be like oh my
God you really did that like you know
something else oh no no no no cuz the
drugs that people say that I don't like
like I did crack before I done PCP like
me all those aren't fun one from her
said dude that's why you put a Wii store
here man put a meth store here bro no
I'm just kidding but you could um but
they're called houses and they're on
11th
Street um no my favorite
druck I got to be honest bro I don't do
drugs cuz Chris Farley like you can't be
fat and do drugs we talked about this
recently if
if it wasn't bad for you look at this if
it wasn't bad for you every single time
someone made a joke I'd like yo you want
a rail right now joke one point one I
know so I can do a eightball every
couple minutes that [__] is so fun but
you can't do it it's bad for you you'll
die here's the thing my dad told me like
this he's like son the coke isn't good
anymore no he's like when I was growing
up and I was doing my thing we had the
best he's said but now this shit's trash
and this was like 15 20 years ago no I'm
40 now so it was like 20 25 years ago so
when I was doing coke I had the plug it
was good it was fun but I can't be big
and do c one just like you and I'm I'm
good on that and it just start getting
hella dirty bro they put fent and
everything right now so it's not worth
it it's not worth your life but you know
hey bro if I can transport and like go
back to the 70s and [__] I probably do
some blow for like a week in Columbia
with some bosses maybe but like you know
it just it's not good this [__] oh I'd
Top This [__] Off I'd start doing it
like those Japanese sand Gardens I'd
spell my [__] name in that [__] in a
laddin where you puts Jasmine in that
thing she's about to die I'll hop in
that [__] right now if it was full Coke
that's how I feel my favorite drug bro
like I'll swim I probably say was assd
when I was doing it never done it I'm
nervous that's the one thing I'm nervous
at this St of Life how old are you
34 might scary I was doing it as a kid
so you didn't really have so many
thoughts so we can go really deep I do a
lot of mushrooms though that's a good
point I [__] with mushrooms yeah you're
way simpler when you're a kid you're not
hell yeah man we're at the [__]
go-kart
place [__] I'm at school my principal
just called me the office cuz my pupils
are big oh you're in San Francisco no I
was in I was in [__] a he went to the
hottest place on Earth to do ass yeah no
that's all they did out there we my
homeboy was on uh probation he had a
piss so only drug he could do that get
out his system was a Oh was so wait wait
first time you ever did I've never tried
it my aunt's friend used to do it with
her when I was a kid and she's
schizophrenic now no [__] will [__] you
up it scared me I think I
I couple people we knew were not the
same from that [__] cuz they did a lot
uh but we did a lot we did it like every
other day for a whole summer and uh I
definitely got caught out of school on
acid my mom defended me it was it was
good but I was tripping hard I was
tripping hard that was my favorite one
though I seen and had the best times on
that so come on man we got to get to one
of these what's the first one who you
know who's the first person gave you a
little tab who was it oh yeah dude my
boy bear dude [__] there we go bear also
you just name bear I mean his name was
he went by Osa for a little bit but bear
I bear gave me my first hit assd but he
also gave me my first sheet
assd you really feel like the he's like
here fool just bring back 100 bucks I'm
like what are you selling for he's like
500 or five a piece I'm like damn I
could make 400 bucks on this [__] I'm
down [__] it had my little hits and had
it poping assd was it was fun for us it
was I don't know why Arizona had hella
acid but they did and then I realized
that San Francisco was like the mecca of
it and [__] but by the time I got back
to the B I was like I'm I'm burnt out on
that [__] oh got you got you so wait you
were doing acid before ninth grade then
yeah bro I'm trying to tell you sixth
seventh e8th grade was [__] oh you
were that kid yeah yeah we have a lot of
those kid you grew up good though yeah I
know a lot of those guys you hang out
with those guys no more it's crazy so
wait wait what what age were you you're
hanging out with the older kids that's
what's going on you're talking about the
older brothers and they're hanging I get
it you're you're that kid you're the
little kid that's like no but he's down
yeah yeah that fo he's with it yeah he's
down what's the first time you ever
tried acid then school at school yeah no
you were how many what were your grades
like what kind of grades did you had I
wasn't good at school all right that's
what I'm asking like there's no way you
kept up me bro I popped ass at school
bro we were being stupid in Arizona BR
Arizona was like an experim it's like
almost like a experiment I feel like put
a bunch of people from different places
that couldn't afford where they lived in
this cheap place and let them go crazy
by a cartel town it's like whoa think
about that when I moved there hella
people from Cali from like New York from
these more expensive places were moving
Arizona cuz it was
sheep a lot of people from all over the
world start coming there and it was
crazy it was turned up fools are getting
down out there it's nuts Jesus Christ a
was kind of turned up but I I was in I
was on acid in school a lot
and I got caught and on at school on
acid uh my teacher let me borrow a
pencil for math class and I was sitting
there looking at him I was like oh man
this dude is [__] crazy full looks
crazy and [__] he's like Gilbert like
what's up he's like do you have my
pencil I'm like oh uh I can't find it
I'm like I don't I don't know where it
is she's like you don't have my pencil I
lent you I'm like no I'm tripped out
he's like I'm calling the security on
you I'm like what so it calls security
and this guy comes in a little golf
court and gets me in his golf cart I'm
frying balls and he's like I can't
believe that [__] guy Mr what's his
name Truman or some [__] whatever it is
would call you for a pencil he's like
I'm about to spin you around and bring
you right back I'm like okay he's like
what' you say I'm like okay I must have
said it where he looked at me he like
what's up with your eyes man oh I said
nothing nothing's up in my eyes he's
like your pupils are [__] huge are
you on crystal or something I'm like no
brought me to the principal's office
principal's like holy [__] what's up
with
this I'm like nothing's wrong with my
eyes man he's like what do you want you
want Coke you want Crystal I'm like no
no I call my mom my mom comes down she's
like what the [__] is going on he's on
drugs and we looked in his in his
backpack and we found money and they had
a bunch of ones laid out but I was a bus
boy at the time my mom's like what do
you think he's selling $1 bags of drugs
these are all one once she like you're
talking about his eyes he always looks
at that she like we've been profiled
since we moved from Cali she like if you
keep [__] profiling my son I'm about
to [__] call the school district and
make a [__] report on your ass
Gilbert we're going home she grabs me we
get in the car she like what the [__]
are you on like I took ass you're
tripping out she said you [__] idiot
we're going home we go home and she puts
me on the couch and she like you going
to sit here you're going to let that
[__] wear off and [__] go to bed
watch TV she turns on the TV it's
[__] uh movie Adam Sandler uh the
[__] the [__] football one it
Bobby
bu I'll never watch that movie again
scared you bro what oh because you're on
assd still I'm so sorry that happened
you I love that damn movie [__] sitting
there watching like oh Mom let me get
out of here I got to go outside no F
stay like C down I'm like I'm trying to
explain to her I wasn't comfortable cuz
his voice and the movie and it's all
weird and [__] I was really it was
really weird to me and everyone's like
watch Natural Born Killers On Acid nah F
watch waterbor acid dog that [__] have
you in a dark place dude the world the
world didn't make sense to me about
anything during that time so like yeah
I'll never do assd again you should try
it it was my favorite drug you should
try it you should try at least once so
don't do it all the time yo Borat I took
too many shrooms and got stuck on board
it scared the [__] out of me and
everybody when I say oh that [__] scared
me they I get the same [__] water boy
I'm so sorry that sucks man but your mom
is so down for doing that no truly like
that's got my back was she is she the
Italian side yeah all right yeah she
wasn't she wasn't having it she said n
you ain't going to profile what do you
want I'm like I'm a [__] ass man you
she was down on their heels and [__]
defending themselves and [__] yeah she
was always down though even like when I
dropped out of school and [__] she had
my back she like I don't know what the
[__] you're doing I don't know what you
think you're about to do but I hope it's
for a bigger purpose what age you drop
out
[__] senior fool oh
you you almost you you were in a dunk
and you missed the layup on that I qu I
quit to work I wanted to work damn
senior year oh it's okay it's okay I was
bartending I I quit High School yeah bro
what do you do you have a beard back
then Forest gum dog I got the story dog
I always should tell you was on the
Marines no in a I'm with the Marines I
was bartending in [__] high school
how do you have a beard back then n my
dad was my dad was in restaurant Biz oh
he ped me up uh for a a bus boy barback
position I was killing it and then one
day someone's like someone didn't show
up and like yo Junior you're in you're
going to bartend tonight and they killed
it and they're like [__] it we're going
to rock with it so from like literally
like right when I turned 18 to like 21 I
bartended maybe like 2021 no [__] it's
the best ever oh you must have some some
Wild Nights from being the youngest oh
what's your name oh oh you smoke weed
but that's why I did Coke and that's why
I even brought this [__] back to AZ
because of that yeah I was in I was in a
mix dog like it wasn't like I was at
like a bar like cheers 4 I wasn't
working at a nightclub dog like Friday
night was hip hop night Saturday night
was [__] techno night and Sunday was
like a [__] salsa night let me roll
you one of these yeah yeah I'm down
I'mma spark this in the meantime thank
you thank you yes but bartending was fun
bro no [__] bartending illegally as hell
sounds
not you you have you have had the Forest
Gump life so far I have bro yeah no
truly are you fast uh I'm just kidding
bro you're not I'm just kid can you run
real fast bro when we ran we had to run
from uh the police one time in Arizona I
was the fattest guy and the fastest guy
so I am fast as well I was out of there
holding your pants up as hard as you can
I'm very uncoordinated I'm very but when
it came to that I was out was gone I'm
like nope not happening to me way all
right first time running from police
what park were you at when you had to
run run we were in like one of those
Shady alleys you you know the little
fences right there like you know you see
in the movies like in LA where F was
like running on like the little on the
tops yeah we're just behind there
smoking and some [__] [__] happened
and we just took off I forgot what it
was I think someone stole some [__] from
uh from a store or something like that
we're just chilling back there smoking
kicking back and
profiled we didn't get profiled we're on
[__] are stealing this [__] all
right all right so so I know we're still
into the early part of your life right
now but I if you got some time I'm going
to we got time brother we got time all
right here we go so one thing that Marty
brought up earlier 18 years of hip-hop
right mhm so you started at what 22 no
hell no uh wait did I 200 maybe I'll
start rapping in high school but I think
the first album came out in 2006 so what
is that how many years is that 22 22 I
mean uh 18 18 yeah 18 yeah that's when
my first album came out I was rapping
before that [__] around with it but
yeah so you're
bartending
trafficking ass Coke back in
for that's that's the best story that
was only one time I'm kidding I'm
kidding bro all right you're bartending
illegally as hell you're working at the
spot dea's like come here and it wasn't
for bartending it was about the weed
[__] so you you you're Force Gump right
now all right for sure dude so and then
you're like by the way I have to hit the
studio
after this Bart gig the [__] you're busy
you're busy yeah you are half Mexican
for sure you're a busy guy but you know
what's crazy if you really look and some
people like man that guy's full of [__]
right but like the good thing is that I
always documented everything and so like
if you go back and watch the first music
video burner just go to YouTube type
burner
burner I'm rapping I'm rapping right I'm
rapping at the bar I worked at oh [__]
he closed that [__] down for the night
and I was like guys let me get the scene
in right here and I had like a little
fake party right there and I did my
video right there at my bar [__] people
always like people that worked at the
bar knew I sold big
weed but wondered why I worked at the
bar and wondered what the [__] I was
trying to do rapping and the people
watching my music mov was like well why
you still working at the bar and why you
was but it all played a big role in
everything I mean it just it was like
life experience [__] for me like the bar
was fun as [__] I mean I was the player
of the year dog like I was 19 18 around
older women all the time yeah I got
money too I'm not the poor they found
out they found out what it what it is
and I just BR just had a good time bro
they they loved I was younger I had fun
doing it right I had access actually
like Hollard DJ is like yo play my [__]
let me hear what it sounds like big not
when people were there whenever want to
leave I was too shy but like play it big
I hear it big I oh this is sick so
Forest Gump is for sure but definitely
evidence and proof mhm yeah mhm all
right I like that I always just like the
thing big too like I was like I'm
working as a bartender I made a lot of
bread too like bartending I made like
$300 to $500 a night damn I made good
money selling weed and I tuck that and I
put it all into music bro I just wanted
to do music all bad so what's your first
out uh the first album I put out was so
I had two projects that came out before
my first album the first project was
um one with Nelly's DJ DJ Tri or
something like that I put together like
12 or 15 songs and let him do like a
mixtape I tried the whole mixtape thing
then we see the benefit of it then I
tried again uh with Dow Jones it was
called uh what is it called Dirty
sneakers right it's me in the strip club
with like seven strippers on my lap and
that was like my first shot at like a
project again with the mixtape and I was
like don't really like the mixtape so
then I went and did a group album with
equipto and that was the one that came
out 2006 but I did two mixtapes before I
even did did the album so I didn't
realize that was the first one you came
out with yeah equipto was the first uh
rapper I ever met in my life I was in
Santa Cruz he was hell nice I was
[__] 14 he taught me how to he taught
me how to write bars he taught me how to
like really like you know [__] with the
music [__] so he gave me a lot of game
and I think I did like maybe like five
or six collaboration projects before I
dropped my actual solo album I was
trying to learn how to rap I just want
to learn I'm like all right I got the
bread from Trapp and I got the bread
from bartend I got the bread from like
my little side hustles being a [__]
buyer at the the hemp Center like let me
now figure out the music business right
let me jump in mhm kind of like where
I'm at now with the film [__] yeah but I
started learning it and I was like all
right if I'm going to learn it I want to
start having other people see who I am
so how do I do that how do I get
exposure go I'm going do a group album
so all the quit those fans can see go
your point in the beginning the dopest
album coveries I feel like he's had
right it was very it was a dope image G
uh the the the cover right track money
pack money dope ass beats big features
we had SEO we had all kind of people on
there be legit um whatnot I put together
a great project wasn't the best rapper I
kind of sucked to be honest with you but
I put it together good yeah I put
together good from the features to the
cover to like an andring and [__] like
that and I had fun doing it and I was
like cool I'm going to run this back
again I think I did my second project
with uh The Jacka I think I did my album
DRFT season with the Jacka that was one
of my questions that was one of your
first ones yeah it was like my second
project I think rest in peace to the
Jack and then people kind of haed on it
a little bit on the drop season one yeah
on the forums and then I went and did
the one with aino and then I did another
one with the Jacka then I did another
one with amp and I did the ones with
Messi Mar and then I put out my solo
album Jesus what was your first solo uh
was it weekend news yeah yeah
boom I have that's the first one I have
son that's the one I got yeah yeah weend
at BR your first one no sh cuz I would
go to Jacks and Maddy's you know so
fresh and then I'd go to streetlight so
I would get all the Bay Area [__] when
it came out cuz everybody would go to
Play The Catalyst right after they do
the signing at So Fresh So that's how I
got all that first [__] I didn't realize
weekend at Beres was your first one uh
cuz drought season 1 is one of my
favorite albums ever still we've talked
about it thank dra season one is and
it's
the crack lader on the pot oh yeah
yeah hard dude that was that was before
people you started HDR those photos
that's that's before that [__] when
started getting like real story about
that cover brother that was a real
kitchen oh really I asked my boy who has
a shadiest looking [__] apartment in
the city right now he said my boy over
here in Leg view so [__] it let's pull
up we pulled up we literally asked photo
doctor this is the realest story ever we
literally pulled up jacket was in a bad
mood I pulled up he's like all right we
going to do it right here he's like
burner do your lighter I did my L he
took a picture of Jack like see it do
done dip damn boy I get a chance to do
[__] that was it one it was a great
picture that was it it looked very
choreograph real deal and what is he in
that one like this yeah cuz he wasn't a
bad mood he did pissed off yeah he was
pissed bro so there's me selling pack
simmer said just I'm working as a pizza
guy right and I'm uh I keep my sign on I
sell sacks and [__] but Jacka Dr season
one and two Weekend at Bernie's um a lot
a lot I was listening to a lot of uh you
remember when uh roach gigs really
popped off right I remember when Dr gigs
popped off and that's when I was like
what is MTV what is it uh what is that
freshman list XXL freshman list that's
the first time I ever heard about it cuz
I only follow you know I was kind of a
snob I didn't listen to mainstream music
it was only Bay are music only or or
super underground like Tech 9 [__] back
when he was still like the not welcomed
you know so I have all the all the first
[__] I have everything I have all of it
I got the whole dis Nation every damn
thing DJ Fresh ever dropped I got it all
so when I'm what I'm talking about is
how did you meet the jck because that's
my what fourth favorite raap how did you
meet The Jacka to begin with and then to
get drought season as him going hey uh
this dude burner's done two albums let
me do an album with him dude was a
blessing that that's that's like how did
you get that I didn't want to say like
why did he do an album with you you
weren't even rapping yet a good question
but I'm trying to ask like to get a a
cosign from have that much Jack for him
to do it yeah yeah that it's actually a
good question a lot of people have
perceived like weird things like people
like oh he's just getting H people weed
and this and that right so by the way
there you go brother it's not it's not
too loose it's a little uncoordinated
you're good you're good uh but I was
walking down hate Street there was a bar
called milk right there and hate and
stanion or not hate and staning yeah
right there by hate the stand right by
meba cross you from meba okay and uh all
the little bartenders I used to work
with used to go over there and kind of
party and [__] like that it was a one
club and see you could actually smoke at
they regular night on Tuesday I went
there every every Tuesday night thought
I was a player over there doing the big
and uh I walked in I seen Jacka just
standing there it's a [__] Jack I'm
like damn this one cherry pie first came
out this before I even knew anyone knew
what it was I was like had like a little
quarter ounce in my pocket I said hey
brother big fan of yours bro I got to
give you a bud and I opened up the bag
he's like who the [__] is that I'm like
that's some [__] we got called cherry
pie he's like that [__] smells crazy G
but he's like man really I need that
whole sack like I'm like oh man honestly
and you have to
remember we're growing back then very
small [__] had like a very that's a lot
though a quarter that's that's $160
especially if you're doing R&D think
about R&D like back before you even knew
what R&D was like we found a really good
strain my God this is Magic we only have
a little bit I'm like I can't give you
the whole sack dude I'm like I I can I
can tell you like half and I'm like wait
I just tell the Jack I'm going to sell
him half like I feel bad bro like I just
told my favorite rapper I'm about to
sell him half of a court I'm like what
the [__] am I thinking he was like but
you don't need that you probably got
more of that boom gave me a little bit
of bread kind I think he actually
overpaid for it and I gave him the sack
and he's like take my number down I need
to know you took my number down text him
and he hit me I'm like bro like I want
to do a record with what does that look
like and uh he's like bro's set it up
then I gave him a little bit of bread he
came up to sing's house we did that song
uh the name of that
song oh [__] I can't [__] think it's
the first song we did bring it up I
can't remember D was was one of the
first songs I did produce it on that
album though yeah it ended up being on
the album we built from there and then
uh try season one and then we ended up
just doing a project we split the bread
and uh we made bread together and uh it
was dope man like he was down down and
[__] with me dude like it just it was a
good look bro like he was a solid dude
and that's the one thing I'll say about
Jack is he gave everybody opportunity
like everyone around him gave
opportunity like my guy with every day
hand I know him through jack like Jack
was kind of like a good door opener for
everybody and he wanted to see everyone
win he would give you the last shirt off
his back he'd be like whatever you need
I got you type [__] he loved weed though
and he was a big weed head and every
time I go to his house I had to hide how
much weed I actually had like cuz I knew
he was going to say you don't need that
you have more of that let me buy it all
so I literally go in there go to his
house I have this jar empty I have the
Char and go in the house I play a game
oh oh I need all that come on you know
you got more than that I have to come on
man leave me a couple buds had to play
Dum and take take a couple nugs and sell
it to him and he was down to buy it he
just wanted it he want he was a pot head
big smoker big smoker I love to hear
this man that's what I wanted to hear
yeah it's big
smok but the strategy was always like
let me show my skills on putting a
project together from A to B and
packaging it and rolling it out right
independently and gain fan base like
that before I Dro My Own solo album so
it's the same kind of concept if you're
like really paying attention to this
interview because I know it goes
everywhere and people like Dam burn
scatter he's Forest come but same [__]
with the film cool let me go ahead and
do this develop a show with a big
company like FX and just gave him
everything I got on this project and
then work on a couple things in the
background
and and you just build you have to build
it and when people ask us for advice on
how to do something we got to build
[__] if they build they will
come straight up so my my approach to
music was like let me try to gain fans
from people that are already recognized
and then I'll drop my solo
out so where did Taylor Gang come
in Taylor Gang was like
2013 I actually just watched a video
before I came here on YouTube it was
like 13 years ago I met whiz at the
dispensary and I filmed it cuz I was
blogging everything at the one you
worked at yeah oh [__] oh [__] you were
still working at the shop in 2013 yeah
damn back when still making records
though I loved it though bro you have to
understand it was I dreamed about that
place at least like [__] four times a
month like I literally have vivid dreams
about me either being back working there
was like you're burner what happened or
like me buying like damn you got the Hem
Center like it was the best time in my
life it was like the most coolest
experience ever I'm a pothead bro like
working there and learning the game
there was the best thing ever happened
to me so I worked there until it didn't
make sense anymore until people were
like you they thought I owned this place
cuz I would always be there I brought
[__] Rick Ross there I brought Drake
there I brought [__] whiz there I
brought Sean Paul I brought everyone
there dude like that place was a [__]
why you just sitting there working there
making music
yeah what what is work you love it
though I think about what my job was and
get high well to get high but also I'm
buying I'm buying packs I'm in the back
I'm the one that people that are vending
weed to got to come see so I'm able to
meet people and I'm able to come up with
connections I'm trapping on the side and
it was perfect for me I was like okay I
can buy good weed for the store but meet
people to buy packs off it to go you
know what I'm saying it was like meet
you outside I was in the network dog CU
I was in the mix and I was bartending
and I was just in the mix and rapping it
was like it was like a really cool gumbo
I feel like it you can't recreate that
kind of motion mhm you know what I'm
saying like where's this movie at
seriously this oh man sh hopefully one
day it is very Forest Gumpy yeah it's
Forest Gumpy I like it that's my second
favorite movie I like it probably had to
be a series though I I I get it I see
that I always thought of the series as
like you know Jesse pinking you watch
Breaking B yeah I love that so what's
his uh he was jumping out of a bitch's
window when they first introduced Jesse
pinkin selling weed wait what was that
kid life I always thought about they
should have traveled with that for one
more episode cuz that's a fun life I
thought about doing it as a movie but I
feel like it'd probably have to be a
series because there's too much [__]
going on and it's a very big story and
there's a lot to
it yeah makes sense can I ask you about
a couple of your tweets that I pulled M
did you or did you not the day before
Christmas Eve see a
UFO oh uh so I thought it was
Theo actually I brought the brought one
of these I was smoking this thing and I
downplay pens sometimes cuz like I
forget that like you know these [__]
actually really work you know so this
one's uh and I'll get to the story but
you hit it once if it turns blue then
blue is uh blue is cereal Al mode you
hit it again and it turns red then you
can hit cereal milk and if you hit it
twice you hit them both at the same time
oh there's two flavors in it two flavors
so it's a dual chamber right and I was
getting obsessed with the fact that get
switch back back forth they hit him both
at the same time and I was actually
tripping that like I was I was enjoying
it like this is one of the pens I
actually really enjoy so I was sitting
there smoking at dinner with my girl uh
and we're driving home we're in tibron
we're about to leave tibron and I was
sitting there hitting the pen I looked
out through the summer I'm like holy
[__] what is that she's like what I did
a little video I'm like babe you see
that I'm like what the [__] and I went
to Twitter and found out within 10
minutes on with starlink man yeah what's
that St starlink Elon mus [__] the
internet [__] you mean the cover up for
UFOs every time you see UFO like nah bro
Elon mus he rich I was high the pen cuz
I was just hitting it all night at
dinner I was just smoking it cuz I'm
like oo I like I forgot about pens I
love pens yeah a two in one that's like
that uh remember the uh the pens when we
were kids you can switch the different
colors on the side so exactly bro that
was my whole thing with this I'm like
how do we make a pen fun again and
actually put real input real genetics in
there I'm like all right cool we're
going to switch back and forth I found
aoke smoke cereal milk I'll smoke cereal
I smoke cereal the mode I'll smoke
cereal the mode if I want to smoke it
both at the same time I'll click it
twice you'll see both colors so it's a
great [__] idea P are [__] good no
that's [__] cool so hold on you know
you've seen you know you oh it's going
to be gone by thank that's going to be
gone by the end of the episode this
[__] is a train you I'm not
kidding not literally been knocking him
down he's a train I don't know what it
is it's the cold weather his lungs are
coated with like a shield from the cold
ice and this mother doesn't cough off
daad don't cough off bomber nothing took
two years to see cough you got try hit
both of them at the same time click
twice so you test have you got have you
ever seen a the mode
uhuh that's gen before
we it's from Kenny Powers too this
smells like
uh this smells like the other the one is
there anything to do with that one yeah
so sir Al Mo times Sher Z that's just s
Alam Mo by okay say kind of hint of that
inside mhm you going say it kind of
smells like a push pop again yeah it's
like a serum this a good serum M
cross before we all get high and get
infat infatuated with this pretty ass
weed that smells awesome yeah it does
you seen UFO you California what's the
first time you ever seen him cuz I know
you have no I have uh's the biggest
place in world time ever seen it was uh
was probably like about like six or
seven years ago straight up like real
one Santa Cruz where you at I was in the
bed
all right I was in the bay just walk me
through that [__] I want to know I was
sitting there on my balcony on my on my
front porch getting high chilling with
my friend and a couple of people and I
seen something pull up like this and
just chill like what the [__] is that
and using technology I get on Twitter
and I see that people are seeing it but
people are seeing it in Arizona people
are seeing it over here people are
seeing it over here I'm like okay I'm
not tripping like what that's why I went
to Twitter right away like Twitter is
like our like Urban like current
newspaper like where the hell do you
find that though I'm on Twitter I don't
see this you just search you just search
topic oh so you're search sorry thought
me you follow some Fools With No I just
search topic and and go latest so I look
just L I'm a lurker on the internet but
I seen that [__] was chilling
kind of hovering and then just gone I'm
like what the [__] I'm like Oh my [__]
do you guys see that everyone seen it we
have videos I have to go back and find
them like dude that's real what the [__]
oh my God I looked up on Twitter and
hella people were talking about that
[__] that's the first time I've seen all
right well I feel you cuz I've seen I've
had like five experien where I'm like
I'm not dumb
look cuz my sister's a [__] uh she
doesn't believe me with anything and she
was with me finally when it happened in
mer said and I've explained it before
but same thing we're driving down the
street something comes up fast dead
stops takes off faster than anything
I've ever seen move in my life not like
so fast it's hypers speed you can't see
it move you can see it go but it's not
like like uh they do in the movies it's
not like the movies where it's
like yeah yeah you could see the
trajectory of it yeah you're like whoa
that's not real like that's not real at
all how the [__] that happened and they
said that the thing I saw end up being
um a test rocket for Elon but this
[__] but [__] because there was
nothing about what how it was hovering
that's a rocket a rocket goes up
[__] that [__] was
chilling right there above the water and
it's seems so close but it seems so far
when I looked it up people were seeing
it from all over the place I'm like it
must I don't know what this is it's
really weird but it definitely like
resonated as something weird mhm and I
seen some [__] in Montana too what where
when I went to go like kind of like star
star like Gaye I got on my boat in the
water yeah went to the boat in the
middle of night oh [__] wait do you live
up there I saw Montana oh no [__] Middle
lake and [__] laid there and just
smoked and like stared at the stars you
can see the starlinks going they go like
that what's that mean like from like you
see him like really going like it goes
like flying around it just it looks like
it's orbiting the Earth right I'm like
what is that and then my boy like that's
Starling so I believe that Starling cuz
it's perfectely doing this but when
we're out there we seen some weird ass
[__] too and I'm just like dude like you
can see the sky clear as broad day out
there it's like you're dancing on the
stars like it's like really really
actually really amazing like you should
probably check that [__] out uh but I
seen some [__] out there too similar
same thing seen something and see just
bolt off and like what the [__] is that
like that's not that's not what I've
seen that's consistent that makes sense
to me that's orbiting our our Earth
that's internet that's it is what it is
but that wasn't what I seen in the bay
and that's not what I seen in Montana I
got to
ask what what made you you go on the
ocean in the night and smoke L the lake
oh God okay yeah the lake well I'm sorry
I'm afraid that sounds so fun though
most peaceful [__] in the world Get
Dangerous no that [__] is fun it's
that's amazing I'm just you know me I
ain't doing it uhhuh yeah hell no no
it's amazing bro I'm just afraid of the
water but I wish I wasn't I like Montana
and lake so much that when I got cancer
the third or fourth thing I thought
about was I ain't never going to see my
leg house again [__] I just bought that
[__] I'm like [__] that's how much I
liked it D you know it's it's sick dude
like it's it's a different vibe it's
really cool it's a it's a good way to
kind of get out there and clear your
mind and kind of remind yourself and
like what's real and what's not you're
just kind of separated from everything
you see nature yeah yeah and you get
those deep winners up there too yeah
really want it Dam I sound so [__]
beast no it's basically Canada like it's
basic there's no light pollution like
it's beautiful you see the sky different
I've never been there but I'm just he
said he went to Montana some Resort
right incredible there same bro it's not
fair time went there was raining
amaz um all right so that sounds the
most peaceful [__] what I say I want to
just smoke a joint in a park and under a
tree mhm I can't [__] this crackheads
everywhere I'm so afraid to fall asleep
and wake up being stabbed [__] that [__]
boy Montana you got to wor about a bear
[__] that's another thing I don't go
to the woods there's animals out beat my
ass I can't fight I can't fight a cougar
I might wrestle that [__] down but this
is not going to be the same ever again
man look I got a roll for you in this
last we're doing called Flathead this
the second film I'm about to do and it's
it's all in one location it's at the
lake it's like a urban like trap meets
[__] uh sleep away camp type [__]
like it's sick dud it's like an urban
slasher it's all about like you know
just us type [__] and then you get to
this beautiful place with lake and water
and cheskis and boats and it all goes
wrong horrible Gore [__] goes down so
you were at that Lake having a great
time with you know what be sick the
opposite of this but a
movie you hitting the [__] out of these
pets bro yeah that's exactly what
happened yeah now I got hiding I was
like this could be a great scary film
and you know what it's a one shoot
location MH you know you're it's
grownups but different MH it's just a
different kind of L someone someone's
getting dumb on the [__] leg like
yeah girl and then comes out of the
water that's not how it's going to be
but you know it's just cool to show like
it's all good until it goes wrong MH
yeah so you are literally every other
high ass dude that just sits there go
you don't be sick yeah for sure you know
be sick and just like but I can make
this uhhuh I could do it that's
tight all right so basically 14-year-old
he very happy and proud and [__] super
stoked with the movies especially did
that [__] though yeah all right all
right hold on hold on before we go into
the topic what's your three favorite
funny
movies um it's hard I know I get it but
how about this not top three what's your
favorite movies to watch that you can
watch over and over that are hilarious
because three favorite comedies is
impossible I think I think I'm trying to
think what really makes me laugh I I
mean it's weird but Blood In Blood Out
makes me laugh as an adult more than any
other can you can you can you please
explain to me why cuz I watched that
movie cuz the only movie we had on on on
my grandma's there's no internet in the
country got blood and blood out I got
blood sport which is kind of odd yeah
blood Sports good and then I had uh uh
speed Blood In Blood Out has like some
of the best quotable lines ever yeah but
what's fun oh you talking about like
popey that's hilarious even he's like
hey G it's still funny I get it popey is
funny D Big's funny big the funest my
dad quotes to no tortilla [__] come on
every morning everyone knows that every
morning bro so I laugh because me and my
homies always get high like oh yeah
[__] popy impersonations or Big Al
impersonation so I think it's funny but
funniest movies uh like comedy comedies
that's full blood and blood I think man
like I'm really trying to get what makes
me laugh these days dude like I could be
old [__] bro was what's 18year oldold
you Billy Madison I was really good to
me I like that movie I'm so sad about
happy about water boy sorry keep going
yeah Billy Madison was a good one I mean
dude [__] his ventur was good when I
was young you know the Cable Guy have
you put your daughter on All these of
course yeah okay I put her on all the
old films like she watched the original
Ninja Turtles dog all say about Space
Jam is she on the Michael Jordan Space
Jam N I've never showed her Space Jam I
was never really into sports but she
watched the real Ninja Turtles though oh
okay she watches like Full House and
like step by step and [__] like that
when she was younger at least put her on
game like this new [__] sucks yeah my
kids know that too like inherently kind
like my pops was coke he was like son
the new Coke sucks sweetie the new show
suck get on the get on the old [__] no
on the same kind of style if we could do
a lifetime listen to music top three
artists maybe albums whatever you prefer
most listen to Lifetime the doors Nana
and Tupac damn yeah
damn Tupac what is happening over here
yo I I get it we talked about on the
show before all this little I don't know
something's up what the [__] is
happening right now bro how could we
haven't been [__] high fiving and
smoking bro I used to think I was going
to be Kurt Cobain's roie dude I was like
the road with Kurt I had long hair dog I
had hair down to here bro Young Stoner
bur had hair down to here I look at the
little
[Laughter]
little I you a little chop yeah someone
called me was your D I was like I'm done
changed at that next day oh I got fat so
I cut my [__] off I was like I was fat
too I was like I look too much like a
girl this is not a good look for me I'm
in the sth grade I saw weed I W to be
that guy yo are you [__] kidding me
the door Nirvana the doors were sick
dude of course the do Jim Morrison's
great you ever heard of love the band
love love no they're uh they're basic
they're they were basically coming up
with the doors but the lead the lead
lead sing was black so they're like yo
we going to go with this this hear about
that's shady my cousin out there is a a
music expert the doors the doors is
[__] dope I just I like how they kind
of like did their thing that's you know
they did their thing and the movie was
really good too which made me like it
yeah good film all right but Nirvana's
probably my
favorite unplugged unplugged out was
dope uh so you listen to like rock as
much as hip-hop basically throughout
your life I used to I listen to rock
like yeah I don't really listen to rap
like that I couldn't even tell you what
new artists are out or what they're
doing I just like to be in my own little
bubble I like to be in my little dream
world from when I was like 16 she listen
like DJ Quick and [__] Warren G and
Dazz and corrupt and [__] like that I'm
old school dude yeah all right so you
okay I wasn't expecting anything you
just said all right so old school [__]
you [__] with Pink Floyd yeah yeah yeah
all right so more that do you like David
Bowie do you like sticky Stardust type
of things or you just like I like I like
I like Nirvana Red Hot Chili Peppers I
like I like gr yeah I like I like uh I
like [__] Tom Petty was pretty dope
Breakers yeah yeah you know a lot of
[__] man like there's a lot of different
[__] like um what that black ho son oh
sound
guardis yeah yeah uh I liked uh I like
green day back in the day like I like
little [__] you know what I'm saying Al
so you were definitely rocking Globes or
DCS and I used to try play guitar yeah I
was I was like you know when I first got
to Arizona before I was you know turned
out by the criminals I was I was going
to be a rock and roll star man that's
what you meant Oh alternate reality Dam
yeah no [__] I was about I should have
been a rocker man damn now another tweet
like you guys seem to be going through
this but it seems like very recently
meta IG hacking you I meant to tell you
with you what I meant to tell you we are
definitely the two most suppressed
people on Instagram by far and when we
get off camera I'll tell you who I think
that group is cuz I've been doing a lot
of research on it like I actually met
people from meta cuz they're fans like
anything else yeah burn I'm your biggest
oh really bro can you give me some
insight I'm not even asking you to do
anything for me tell know why can you
just tell tell me why happen what
happened just tell me what happened
please like explain to me what I what
did I do and what's happening and I
started hearing about it and you know
it's a group out there that just don't
want people to have a certain voice and
it's scary because the pay toplay [__]
could happen to people that have a real
audience a real fan base people want to
see and hear from both of us people want
to understand what we're doing what
we're building but they also know that
that's powerful and so there's a group
suppressing that and I meant to tell you
I'm glad you brought that up because I
was going to tell you when I got here
before we started on camera bro I think
I figured out who's hitting a lot of
people [__] it's a group and uh it's
crazy and it's [__] up and meta you
guys should not be doing that
a lot of the people there are fans of
mine they get all excited want to take
pictures on I see them and it's just
some [__] pay to play [__] right now
that's what it really boils down to
that's why I built social club and I
wish I could figure out how to get it
popping I don't even use Social Club I
can't because there's no one on there
like that like you know we we have a
couple thousand people that would try it
and I got a bunch of weed brands that
try it it's hard when it's so directly
weed you know what I mean because it's
it's like you got a game what what got
Instagram popping
everyone was on it well that's the thing
so like I want to figure out with a key
group of people how to make Social Club
a thing because it's not just weed right
we have this new thing we put payto
playay broadcast so like you're a
business in [__] LA or you're a
business in the bay or you're a business
in a small town in Montana you want
people around you to see your [__] like
you can go literally go to your settings
on soci social club and put 03 MI6 mil
or 10 mies and see whatever is being
posted right there that's pretty sick we
got audio comments we got [__]
stories we got posts we got everything
that Instagram has plus more we have we
have type cap type posts so you can type
about hey guys I woke up this morning
I'm feeling great comment below if you
want this post right like so like
Twitter mix instead of having to go do a
tweet screenshot and post it right we
just thought about all this as young
marketers right but I can't get off the
ground for the life of me bro I put
millions of dollars behind this [__] I
want to see it go I don't have the
bandwidth and I also lost faith in it
but for anyone watching
come up with a plan I'm down for
whatever interns help me figure it out
cuz it's there for us to use but
Instagram is on some
[__] [__] okay it's [__] up
because you will see your business like
I built my business and my brand on
Instagram so I got popping yeah there's
no secret recipe I was before I could be
Shadow band and silence MH and even
people at met like yo we went into your
account we trying to fix it but you got
so much [__] going on we just can't
manage it every day it's impossible
did they tell you you're you're on a
list oh yeah all right they're like
you're on The Black List that's told
Black List well that's what the guy told
me it's not a Black List what it is is
you're on a list of people that have
people that work there that go in and
[__] with their [__] oh so it's like
think about a Cop there's a badge
there's like a code of honor with the
badge so if you're at meta and someone
calls you about you know someone's
account but your homeboy is the one
going in there and [__] with it cuz
he's getting a little side dough like
a bro you're you're on a list yeah it's
a way of saying bro you're part of this
extortion circuit because people there's
a big [__] business in that your page
to get it back up I've gone through all
this it's a group bro that's doing this
and it's so so scary bro because our
[__] could you could digitally die mhm
you could digitally usually die straight
up and I've had meetings with people at
meta their high up cuz I'm I'm not going
to downplay I'm a [__] boss I can get
in the building they're like yo you're
not doing anything wrong you can post
weed you know you can post weed right
we're terrified to post [__] anything
I can't post [__] look at Vias papers
I'm not going to go there but look at
visas papers I can't even post a pack of
papers cuz they'll get deleted saying
promoting [__] illegal I'm like on
the on the page on page I'm like this a
pack of paper there's no weed there's no
weed there's not even to [__] roach
your ass there's nothing yeah but point
being is they can decide they they told
me right there like yo you're not
posting anything wrong you can post weed
you just can't tag or redirect on how to
buy the weed so I could put a post up
and say this [__] C MO shery is
beautiful it tastes great I love the way
it makes me feel have you ever tried it
and they cannot delete it but if me and
him post it two seconds oh was you can't
you can't do that I was say you giv an
example I thought you were saying what
you can do no you're like the normal
person can yeah normal person can can't
it's not against the rules I I got gamed
up from top person you can ever imagine
in the whole world that works there and
they told me everything I could and
couldn't do and I followed into a te
after calling him 10 times he's like ber
I just don't have the time to manage
your account we're running a full
company over here sorry damn it just
you're you're getting [__] with and I
think you know it I'm like cool all
right so we've been RPD on Instagram
brother yeah yeah I look at your [__]
I'm like there's no way I know what kind
of weight you pull dude I'm not dumb I'm
in this space I've been in space for a
long time like people [__] with your
[__] you have a good audience you have a
real audience and to see the kind of
Engagement you have is hella sad because
crazy on this it's my 30th account yeah
it's number 30 I don't get the account
back that's the problem if I get deleted
it's
gone I started a new one new email they
do it to where they zap your phone too
where yes I get a new phone so exactly
yeah yeah I had a new phone I've had a
traded so Apple loves my ass you think
it's Apple they're like yo these FS buy
phones every month no I'm kidding bro
I'm kidding you know what it is but you
know what though I just have to say this
cuz I know it's going to be a
controversial clip if it comes out Solo
or people watch it you have to be a
miserable [__] to pay somebody
to silence someone's Instagram 100% you
got to have a baby dick you got no life
and no taste you probably eat Spam every
day with nothing on it like you are not
exciting at all you probably eat chicken
out the can like what
chicken those you're one of those kind
of [__] guys so like of course going
to want to not see me live life
[__] yeah it's so like confusing
to me that that could be like that's
what's going on like unless it's like
some competition comp bro I can tell you
right now 100% facts and trust your boy
dude your boy was touch the cover of
Forbes I'm I'm in them buildings we're
doing nothing wrong there's no list
there's no there's no no Rhyme or Reason
either right no but there's also no list
meta does not have an agenda against
individuals I talked to some of trying
to say it without saying talk to some
big dogs over there and there's no list
of like yo we don't want this maybe on
some like major like political [__] but
in our world is so small to them they're
like dude no maybe it's about some like
politician campaign [__] or around the
elections that's something way bigger
than me or you will ever be yes talking
about two guys that have audiences
that's a targeted [__]
attack let's pay to play [__] within the
within the is that do with egg he just
doesn't want to see us win they call me
a
SP you it's just like it's just elevated
throughout the years in technology the
egg is now Instagram
account yo so no matter what no matter
how many stores you have it still
doesn't matter they still don't like no
it doesn't care so I'm just saying it
from from my from my perspective I've
tried to figure it out I've literally I
don't give a [__] about writing School
I've written out don't do this don't do
that all right cool Count was debted uh
that was I I posted with just a tweet
saying is my account
gone my dog got deleted one time time
bro that's when I it was [__] me it was
was my mom a it's a labrador dude
there's no violations bro it said
violating graphic this and I'm like what
and it got wait the account got got
deleted no my post got removed oh oh oh
oh sorry I thought you made to delete
the whole account for the dog to again a
little message to our [__] ass
haters I'm still there at least for a
reason because they know I've wiggled my
way up there and told him I'm not doing
anything wrong so at least I can
unfortunately I can for I'm fortunate
enough to get my [__] back but doesn't
mean I won't be Shadow banned have post
deleted be put on noticed I'm going lose
my account I've lost my account been
able to get it back thank God mostly
because the music stuff though it has to
be because you can get the check mark
without having to put your full [__]
name in that most music [__] but I bro I
see other people getting done dirty and
I've always watched you get done dirty
and pisses me off cuz I'm like I know
for sure the same kind of people people
are hating on him that's hating on me
now I'm fighting us probably the same
group honestly it's a very weird thing
and it goes back to what we talked about
with that weird competitive weed [__]
when it went wreck there's people that
are just scared of people with [__] a
voice cuz we could actually move
mountains if we had a real reach I mean
you guys are the first generation of
like entrepreneurs that are building
businesses through the fan base
online I mean for
real Brands and selling directly to the
customer I'm down to find out how to get
Social Club popping with everyone I'm I
don't even it's not about even making
money at this point like I just already
put the money there the money is gone
it's an app in the app store right yeah
that's right available M we could do
some cool [__] like that one yeah no I
was going to say I gotta be honest hit
me but it tastes creamy yeah it's momb
it's cre could you do me a favorite
could you get me a water out the fridge
I just realized the yeah yours is right
there too by the way right um
so I I'm not this is we're I'm still got
questions I have never been more excited
to go show's over who is it I can't wait
to you to say the words cuz I I I've I
know I put this on paper I I've talked
about it bro I moved out here I didn't
get paid for [__] I was making a $3,000
a month and then they took away my push
trees page the day they offered me the
blue check I just moved here and I was
like all right so you cut off 90% of my
money cool cuz I stopped thank you stop
selling weave I'm in this I can't go
back dude so to hear that it is
something and it's not just something
I'm doing maybe I'm being explicit maybe
that DM where I said hey stop being a
[__] got me deleted but I heard the
rules from the top and we're not
violating any rules and they helped me
multiple times get my page back like
they would they literally help me get my
[__] back I'd be like you get monetized
you could do this you can go live and
then like the next day boom boom boom
boom boom I'd hit them they get it back
and it got to a point they're like this
is nonsense bro like you're one guy bro
like sorry bro like you must have done
some real [__] to piss people off but we
can't help you anymore burn like the
best thing we could do is just tell you
like the rules which you're following
and if you ever get deleted extend to
all Branch we'll try to get your [__]
back because you're we know you're not
doing anything wrong like
[__] all right so Marty that makes me
feel a lot better I mean I've been doing
this for 11 years on Instagram where I'm
just going so what's the problem so so
it's good to hear that it's not just
it's not me no it's not just me it's not
that I'm doing nothing I'm doing dumb to
get all the way out like so people don't
think we're conspiracy theorists and
[__] if you're just posting nothing but
weed weed weed weed algorithm will pick
up and [__] but the kind of [__] that we
get deleted for or like the kind of
things we post is just unheard of MH
yeah like I said my last account got
taken down longest one I've had in years
I had it for a year and a half and I
posted happy birthday Mom picture of me
and my mom they got taken and the whole
account gone yeah that's spiteful [__]
was even getting high yeah spiteful yeah
okay all right so let's let's skip a
little bit back more on topic here we go
here we go for current things as of now
you have you had an album that just came
out with o yeah all right so how did how
did how did that go cuz is that part of
your 50 albums collaboration albums and
everything right overall yeah so you're
dropping [__]
consistently damn near
quarterly uh not quarterly if it feels
like it because I'm looking through
everything when I was going through the
list I SL down a little bit like in the
last few years but like I at least try
to drop like two or three projects a
year or something like that at least so
how often does that have you in the
studio just I mean last night I have
like three things kind of skeleton ready
to go for this next project and that was
just one night so I mean typically for
album like seven days seven days to make
it yeah six seven days no [__] really
from start to finish
what yeah you're talking about like from
getting the Beats new or you already
have the songs all done ready to go no
no I just get beat folders I go in there
I get really high it's like it's on
YouTube a couple I put like 30 40 jars
of weed all kind of hash I just sit
there and get comfortable and we order
good food and we start getting real high
and start diving into it and I'm very
militant like I don't have hell of
people in my studio it's not a party
it's me and engineer maybe a couple
people and I've even have the homies go
chill they probably get mad they go
chill and [__] other I don't really
have people in there I just work yeah
just work I'm there to work because I
don't have time
to make music it's actually like
a actually a blessing I get to make
music anymore I'm so busy with other
business [__] with all the companies and
stuff like that so I have to bang it out
I don't have a choice you don't have
time to sit around and like oh here this
would be a cool concept you know let me
do this or do that I see what you're
saying we just banging this [__] out
real quick the mass amount of music that
you put out would have me thinking that
you're just a studio rap I ain't gonna
lie like I'm not over there trying to
make his singles like let me you think
about catchy Melody like ah I'm not I'm
just like talking just get [__] in your
life therapy yeah we work fast seven
days for I we we have a lot of artists
on here we always ask that question I've
never heard of MH I like that he's like
this is my album week yeah smart like
bro we had it booked out I was supposed
to be in New York from like the 10th to
the 14th and I had the four days of Bang
Out the album right there and then that
that trip got cancelled so last night I
had the time off I was here to do this
went in there
for maybe like six 5 or 6 hours how long
were we there for last night like 5
hours a little bit longer than that 5
hours banged out a full song two verses
in a hook then I did another verse in a
hook and pulled up like another verse I
worked on like week before and just kind
of cleaned it up and boom done so
there's three songs ready to go I just
got feel in the little I'm going got F
in the little gaps and that's it is
there somebody that really stands out
that you've collaborated with like this
[__] is just so talented in the
studio dude yeah there I worked with
some dope ass people I think uh I mean
[__] Stephen Marley and Damon Marley
is probably the best they it really Tri
me out it was just different it was a
different vibe and like different like
actual musicians really in there yeah
sick
uh [__] Cameron was super dope he
works like me like when I did the
project with cameraon he was like all
right I'm going to go write in the car
while you write your verse I'm like I
love this like we're here to do business
we knock this out so while I was rri my
verse he'd go in the car write his he'd
come in L his I go in the front Lounge
right mind like we're actually really
rapping rapping uh and uh what is there
a reason why you guys left the room each
time because like if there's a beat
pulled up and he's rapping his [__] I
want to still write my [__] you got to
keep bringing it back bringing it back
yeah you don't want to like make them
sit there and listen to you while you're
trying to write your [__] so you have a
beat playing and then if I'm like I'm
about to lay my verse you're like all
right cool I'm going go out there and
write this real quick so he's not
listening to me do my thing uh Cosmos is
one of my favorite guys to rap with he's
I always feed off his energy
um trying to think who my I've worked
with everybody bro what was uh wax room
like making that's one of my favorite
songs one of the first songs I heard oh
man that song was dope man like we uh my
boy Nemo fadavi sent me to beat I loved
it right away and then uh I made it and
I was like man who should I put on here
and me and nipy hustle was dming a lot
at the time he hit me up a lot he
actually really gave me my flowers as a
rapper he's like bro you really really
doing that [__] bro he's like uh your
music's dope I see you pushing like we
should build and I was like damn like
this nipy hustle at this dope and then
um I hit him one day I'm like bro I got
a record I want you to get on I'm like
this would be cool to put him on this
cuz it's such a different record yeah
like it why would nipy hustle be on wax
stre but I like to do [__] like that
yeah so I hit him up he was like I got
you bro pull it to the studio I went
down there and pulled up and it was
hella deep in there I pulled up Solo in
the Uber he was hella deep in the studio
he put the beat on he bodied it right
there for me did did that for me and I
was like damn you're a real one brother
and then uh came to shoot the video and
um he I came out to LA to shoot the
video and we're supposed to shoot the
video and he just didn't show up that
day and answer his phone and [__] I was
like damn like I didn't blow him up too
much cuz I respected he must have had
something else going on or whatever but
he hit me a day or so later he's like
bro I'm sorry dog like I got caught up
in some real [__] you know don't even
want to talk about it he's like but I'm
not like that to leave you hanging so
put your camera man with me I'm going to
bang my scenes out I'll go to the same
place as you went to so it could be
consistent whatever I'm like nah bro
don't even worry about it just hook up
with the homie and bang it out and he
did it he sent that over and I was like
that's the Real's dud in the game
because he was popping at that time bro
and he didn't have to do that for me at
all and he did that he did on his own
hooked up with the guy took care of him
was hella you know good Hospitality with
the homie shot his scene send it to me
no one ever would have known it went
down like that but wanted at least speak
to his character like that dude with
super sa so
yeah wa was just one of those
things good
song it's fun doing that live too so the
the cookies Christmas yeah right how
many years you been doing this [__] bro
I don't know maybe like 10 damn for real
maybe maybe maybe [__] maybe damn all
right my my brain is I was in BL at
least five years man yeah I'm burn okay
see it's 2017 we were just talking about
this earlier that [__] was 7 years ago
now so that that really put perspective
the pic wiped my memory out yeah I mean
I was I think the first time I did it
was at Slims or something like that in
San Francisco right yeah I think that
was the first one then we did the
Regency a couple years I think and then
we did Warfield for at least like five
or I don't know man I'm [__] lost too
but yeah more than five for sure seven
to 10 MH and this year was with ogz and
Mexican OT yeah good [__] all right it
was a good lineup br bro people showed
up for that [__] of course they're going
to show that's energy that's dope that's
that's that's a good lineup he just
pulled right there
yeah it's wild seeing like how much he's
blown up Mex he's blown up in this past
year he's doing his thing yeah like it's
so cool to see like somebody especially
like out of Texas we talking about him
for a few years now that feels
hard he's very talented he's young too
he's like 20 [__] 3 or 24 I didn't
realize he's hella young yeah was a
little kid oh I know that he's just in
the game bro he's so fresh he has a lot
of opportunity bro like he has I see a
lot of uh potential with that guy right
there he's about to kill it for sure um
not to switch
up little frequencies here but I had a
question and we're were talking about
all this positive [__] it's probably
going to be a little more on the
negative side but I got to ask because
it's very uh relative to my life because
I feel you I I get tagged on everything
obviously I get tagged on everything so
I see everything people tag me on
everything the [__] so when they tag me
on [__] I'm like oh damn that's sad but
at the time I'm like me and you I'm like
uh he'll deal with this thing like I'm
doing my thing that sucks why have LRG
LRG yeah oh man uh so I know you had
some [__] happen so did I but I want
to know what happened so LRG uh we did a
collab we did cookies LRG collab I'm
very thankful they introduced me like to
the whole Zoomies business I think
that's maybe why I got into the Zoomies
but I did a rolling tray collab in that
capsule and um LRG offered to buy
cookies for a million dollars a million
I was like no bro we're not thinking
we're not dreaming the same I'm not
going to sell cookies for a million wait
hold on sorry what year is this man we'd
have to look it up it was it was back
when that capsule came out must have
been [__] we've been cookies has been I
think cookies has been a thing for about
10 years officially the clothing line so
it must have been about like eight years
so like seven eight years ago or
something like that I think our our
times are messed up cuz push tre's been
around for 10 years oh really you've
been around longer than that I don't
know I'm old man I'm lost cuz so fresh
remember I told you I had the first the
the Girl Scout logo with the girl
blowing the smoke that sh wor some bread
that's that's the one that's that's the
old the first one yeah that that was and
I was
21 that was 13 years ago [__] so if you
think about it cookies is at least 12
years old yeah at least I'm I'm actually
going to get these facts I should know
this because cuz I'm thinking of it now
cuz I know you guys were around before
we were MH so when I'm thinking about it
cuz I have my cookies think there's no
way they offered you a million dollars
somebody that fo had no intentions of
giving that's the dumbest number I've
ever heard my life he off me a million
bucks I was like I think I'm good on
that bro good [__] though and then I
seen him post a tray you're making more
that was the exact same mold as the tray
I and I designed this tray I invented
this tray this one I thought it was cool
with the tips with the tips and little
removal astray and that was my [__] I
designed it I made it [__] that was
was my [__] I sat there at a cafe with
my boy and handrew that [__] out with
him and he mocked it up and got the same
I did it as mine so when they when they
ran it I could just called them out I'm
like dude you guys are some on some
[__] ass [__] dud why would you even
take my [__] got me [__] up and that
was like one of the first different
rolling trades than one I designed that
was like back in the days when I used to
have other people distri my Distributing
my [__] and whatnot but anyways LRG
stole my tray I was pissed I just kind
of called him out for it I've been cool
with them ever since I never really had
no other problem oh [__] damn I thought
it was something way different I got
tagged a thousand times I thought it was
all some [__] no what' you think
what you hear I thought they like stole
your capsule or selling your
[__] that's the I I don't dive into into
like I said I'm like oh negative as hell
that's sad as hell was it like some
designs they flipped or something like
that that's what I thought this was
about like they stole your capsule and
then I just read the post and that was
it oh no no there was the rolling tray
that's all I know about unless there's
been other [__] that's not that's not
nearly as bad as I thought it was man LG
they're dicks what they do that's why
I'm saying there's no way that guy had
any kind they offered me way more money
than that and I'm that's just me there's
no way in hell they offered you that and
that's guy had any power at all cuz they
offered me way more money than that for
push trees back when somebody we both
know when I was friends with him and uh
they offer me way more money than that
and what happened was you know who the
person I'm talking about I don't take
him serious
and he's on the phone just being loud
and I'm like all right be loud and I'm
over here and then I'm just on my phone
doing comments and this F walks in how
much you sell puss trees for and I go
nothing cuz I'm a I know what the [__] I
can do I'm not selling my [__] and
that's back when I was like I need $700
more for my rent I need to make that
[__] like I was struggling I was
struggling when I turned down the M2
though yeah you feel me the bank is
different than and cash like a bankable
money is Big you know so you see you see
so you feel okay so I'm in the same
exact boat when they did this to
me and then I'm like nothing and he goes
and he walked out the room I'm sitting
there doing comments and he comes back
in he goes yo LRG says how much you want
he give you $10 million right now M yeah
[__] I'm doing comments how much you
sell it for right now come on I don't
want to tell him to suck my dick I was I
was being a dummy I was just being
stupid with my home like Tell suck my
dick and I went back to and he looked at
me and he walked out the room I'm like
what the [__] was that look and he comes
back in he's like I the [__] owner on
the phone you say suck my dick this
whole thing we get his yelling match cuz
I don't believe his ass that he has the
owner on the phone come on your dumb ass
got the owner on the phone and he did
damn so remember hustle trees came back
out of life yeah that was two months
later after I told him to suck my dick
ah they had a cup a booth at the cup and
that's when I'm like yo you got two
booths I'm like what do you mean like
you don't have two booths as I'm selling
people clothes they're like no oh you
can do collab with go what did you just
[__] say and then that's when I saw
the hustle trees booth and then those
fools tried to fight me LG dudes did two
of the dudes from the booth were dogging
me and then that's when we've did the
whole story time about it they rubbed
their [__] reclaim all over my [__]
the first time I ever had a booth with a
rack I was broke in my like renting a
car trying to get all that [__] into a
car to come to the event in LA while I
was living mer said and then I'm like
why are they standing over there and
then those fools walked up by the taco
truck they kept staring I know when
someone wants to fight me you know when
someone wants to fight you and I was
like I'm
ready I was just mad cuz like hustle
trees everything [__] you guys damn and
then I when they left I walked over
there and there was reclaim all over my
shirts like they just wiping dabs off
that's what I said every shirt counted
back then and they wiped it all over my
[__] shirts dude damn like did you
ever talk to owner again or no I never
met the guy when I go to the damn what
what place do they own down there uh
treeh house I don't know the the the
venue in OC oh yeah uh [__]
Observatory twice they try to not let my
ass in when I'm I was with MC Miller
damn and they tried to not let me in I
walk in with these guys crazy yeah so I
had some beef with these fools for a
long time and then they brought hle
trees back and then I was like oh wow
that sucks because you guys they made
one shirt in 2004 that's at hustle trees
and then they tried to make a whole
company after this and they try to get
in the week game and all this [__] off
Vengeance basically they didn't they
didn't really know what they were going
to doing they they had a powerful
company and it kind of fell apart and
sad ending like it's my favorite company
dude it's still around I used to rock
LRG every day every day BR I used to go
buy a fresh LRG fit every day I'd go to
the [__] spot on H stre I walk in
like all right we got this this s give
me all of it wear a fresh one every day
give to Ray bomber from runs he'll tell
you he used to come to my [__] bro my
closet was stack to the top homie like
when I was balling giraffes and trees
all just [__] clothing they' come to
my spot all my little homies come there
and take fresh outfits I was like bro
I'm not rocking again I had that kind of
Pride I was getting money and uh user
with the shoes I used to [__] I used
to rock LG every day every day every I
mean I was broke and I would save up
like I'm going to get $32 on jackets
Jack the jackets were so sick or Dr
Jay's Dr J W that shirt's a little
cheaper on Dr Jason makes it so much
worse I used to do that [__] man I was
selling little saxs I'm going to get a
new shirt all right but I remember like
when I started selling packs I my [__]
was LR jeans remember that I was stacked
man I need them altered that company man
they they did they did a good job for a
while but I think at the end they just
got like desperate and they had some
weird leadership and just got funny you
know something happened but yeah I
wanted to I didn't when Jon was when the
original owner was in power and the
original team was rocking that [__] was
UN stable was the biggest thing on earth
yeah and I feel like when he passed away
there wasn't proper guidance rest in
peace to him he's a legend from our area
I think when he passed away there wasn't
a proper guidance people just kind of
didn't really keep his vision his kind
of like energy alive they kind of just
went super corpor with it just kind of
killed that [__] that's why I got my
will if I die there's certain people in
position keep my [__] alive [__] that
yeah just to make it corny yeah but damn
that question oh was negative as hell
that wasn't near what the hell happened
to me they stole Marvel and my bad they
just stole your [__]
okay no anything you make that came from
your brain and someone else I'm sure
people they do it all time knock off uh
there was a story I heard like eight
years ago that you had people or you
going and finding fake cookie [__] in
stores Is that real I don't know oh okay
sorry I know it was bad I don't know
because I've had people show me push
tree [__] I've gone in there by like yo
what the [__] you doing but it's though
it's my small town a couple of my homies
like bro we're sick of seeing this [__]
bro we're going to go [__] make our
own moves we're about to pull up on
fools I'm like bro it's not worth it man
leave it alone and they pulled up and
they try to make a statement on my
behalf on like bro it's probably not the
best move to make but they felt a
certain type of way CU I take care of
all my people and like man people are
really just selling this [__] however
they want to like you're not going to do
nothing I'm like kind of like
cheerleaders in a way but like you know
I Don't Really Want To Hurt No Smoke
shot business or nothing like that and
they're like [__] that we're going to go
say something I'm like all right and you
know I got real people around me they
just weren't feeling this [__] cuz I've
helped them out in many ways and they're
like [__] that [__] if you're not going
to say something we are it's kind of
like that's what happened it's like the
friendly kid that like doesn't want to
fight at the playground but his is like
[__] that [__] you man get over here
boom whoops their ass for you like got
you brother like that's kind of [__] you
know but all right that's same thing
with my little brother the flea market
Merc said this fool was just printing
everything I've ever
dropped for $10 like you B it's not even
the money thing it's people see that and
go this is the quality your sh BR we
have we have the US [__] what's this
[__] called the the not C it's a customs
yeah we have Customs hitting us up from
like where the boats come in all kind of
fake cookie [__] dude like I'm talking
about like all kind of fake pens and
this and that blah blah blah like they
hit us up as a compan like yo is this
[__] yours like [__] no it's not ours
all right cool well we just seiz this
blah blah all right cool rock with it
like people bootleg the [__] cookies is
probably like the most bootleg brand out
there I feel like
weed that's what I was going to ask is
one worse than the other or they both
equally boot like I the weed stuff is
worse but the clothing shits everywhere
I yeah just the myars and [__] well
myars and like the all the fake 510
that's see the cheapest pens that's why
when we did this pen the one I gave yall
we had to come with like something cool
I'm like I don't want my [__] to look
like every other pen out there and I
want to do something different in a
sense like functionality a little logo
belt right in yeah well if someone makes
that they have to put in some work dude
that's that's not easy to make and
actually function like that then it's
almost like all right you deserve
yeah [__] if you're going to go that far
just make your own brand of that
[__] Jesus Christ if you're going to
put that much work into it cheerleaders
bro that's why I love a different level
of being bootleg did you have a AI
impersonation interview come out
craziest thing I've ever seen in my life
bro did a fool you for a second what
happened bro first of all to have like
AI generated interview is insane but to
have a AI generator interview for
someone that's alive and in contact with
that company I've done I was a keynote
speaker at their events they know me
they have my phone number so you're
going to believe I did a a piece that
was H negative on me and I responded to
hella crazy ass questions you didn't
even hit me up like bro how do you feel
about the story coming out this writer
like it just was hella weird but they
apologized they deleted
it I was audio no it was it was uh It
Was Written but I think I want my get
back on that though just do that right I
think i' honestly I feel like my I've
been damaged by that mhm I think it was
what did they say he he's the one that
told me about it I just saw it as a
headline I don't really know what
happened there was like a hit piece it
was like burner's Empire some fire and
this and that like it was like a like a
shady ass article like I'm just falling
off or some [__] right meanwhile cookies
had this best year and whatever when
when Le to that but point being is it
was like a hit piece on me and the
interview was asking hell negative [__]
it was like what do you think about your
you know allegations to human
trafficking I was like I don't think
that
like what I would like [__] ass
[__] what are you even saying to
me what did you just say to me bro
you're accusing me so they said some
wild ass questions and they had this AI
burner answer like a lawyer wrote it for
me and it looked really shady and I'm
like I posted I'm like I first seen it
I'm like what the [__] is this it's
actual interview I'm like let me read
I'm like that's not the way I talk I'm
like what the [__] is this so I put it
on Twitter I'm like that ain't me and
people are like okay maybe maybe not but
then someone from the SF Chronicle I
think or SFGate one of the other my bad
whoever it is thank you for doing this
ran some kind of program and said this
is a 100% proven it's AI generated we
ran through this program and we could
tell that it's written by AI so we hit
up the platform benzinga I'm like what
the [__] is this oh well the riter
doesn't work for meninga he's contracted
and he had credible sources well who are
they and you look up these people and
they look fake it's like a fake profile
with like fake images like of like like
a like almost like a catfish lifestyle
Instagram like this person's not real
you know what I'm saying what so it was
a pay-to-play situation for sure and I
say that because the the interview was
monetized and they had they had hell
connections with me the the people over
at Benz could have called me and said
hey we want to do interview with you now
the one thing I know about being in
position people will have negative
things to say about you you can't stop
St at all I don't really give a [__]
what people say so I wasn't upset that
there's a hit piece on me but I didn't
answer those questions those are my
words and a platform can't put that kind
of [__] out there and say this is what
burner said to allegation like this cuz
i' be like what the [__] did you say to
me you're accusing me of what cuz I rap
about [__] I'm a human trafficker
[__] that's [__] weird [__] that
sounds like you guys try to that's try
to cancel my ass exact and it it didn't
work again but well they got ads all
running on that [__] that's the whole
point and it was like on Apple and all
kind of other platforms so I mean those
guys definitely owe me an apology that
seems super illegal to do yeah it's
super illegal you can't do that any real
platform that does like journalism knows
that you can't do that you have to check
your facts you have to fact check an
interview and you can't misquote
somebody on some [__] they didn't say
you can't have an interview with a fake
person
yeah no this doesn't work could you
imagine if they sampled your voice from
that's what I thought you me like when
they did the Rogan [__] you see that
roken AI interview Tik Tok Clips yeah
bro it's getting scary what people are
going to try to do but the good thing is
like look dude we all aware that there
[__] like this there they're going to be
able to do a burner
AI leaked audio because look how many
hours there are of interviews and songs
and [__] AC capellas and they could
do but is it real or not I'm glad there
is programs out there that can actually
tell whether it's real or not think sh
shout out to the tech nerd doing that
[__] yeah to all the fools out there
delet oh God you get canceled over a
[__] AI interview y I'll fight
somebody they tried they tried to cancel
my ass hell of times it's crazy who the
group the group the group damn it's
somebody I went to high school with was
it down ass who no it's some f i [__]
skimped on his ha or something that's
what I always think like do I know
somebody did I say something offensive
cuz I say some offensive [__] no at the
end of the day bro I find it flattering
that someone spends their time I did a
post the other day I said look all the
time you spent trying to cancel me do
fake interviews pay people to get rid of
my Instagram post or silence me or pay
people to [__] try to get at me right
bro you could just spent that trying to
build something yourself because the
whole time you're doing that even though
I know who the group is can I be honest
with you you know what I'm going to do
about it nothing I'm gonna go focus on
different products different projects
movies [__] all kind of [__]
because my energy is focused on [__]
that pushes my business forward those
guys are stuck in a khole trying to
figure out how to take my business down
but that leaves their business where all
that time they're spending on my
business I'm spending all my time on my
business you're neglecting your business
so you guys can keep trying to cancel me
but I think that over the years I've
only grown and growing and grown and
growing because I'm still focused on my
[__] I'm not getting engaged I know who
the group is but all I'm going to do is
tell my friends who it is and spread the
word like that that's awesome and I'm
not going to try to Counterattack or try
to hit or do this or that that because
then I won't be focused on my business
I'm about money I'm about Legacy I'm
about doing dope things so I'm not going
to focus my energy towards that that's
makes sense is there anything you set
out for in 2024 like I'm trying to hit
these Milestones this year hell yeah I'm
trying to get that show fully developed
and get that out that would be dope as
[__] and then I'm definitely trying to
get my first film done and find a good
distribution platform for it
independently and definitely [__] ready
for my son for sure I'm definitely ready
to take a few months off of my son
when's the due date March 2nd oh so it's
coming up been a long time since you had
a newborn right 16 years I'm 40 about to
have a kid it's kind of weird oh you
it's a half Mexican side of you supposed
to have kids at
51 no it's just cuz my little brother
you want to know our age Gap it's 25
years
damn my little brother's at Universal
Studios he's 10 or he's yeah he's 10
Jesus hey that's real [__] though no I'm
just like what kind of shoes you want
fool what else what else do you like a
fortnite this F been playing fortnite
for 4 days straight dude he doesn't want
to do nothing but go play fortnite uhuh
but it's like all right and my other
little brother's 19 my old sister's 20
or 19 then 16 so like I got a lot of
what do you need fool like what do we
got to do like it's it's it's a lot of
25 years makes me feel better my my 16
years is making me feel wild but 25
years is that's 25 my uncle to my dad is
24 crazy it's that they just like yo you
want to have a baby take 15 years off
and you know what we're bored right now
let's [__] have another kid ah it's
hella funny it's the truest thing all
you out there go yeah my brother's 19
years older than exactly that's good
though that's the way it happens kids
are good it's a good balance bro
honestly 2024 bro I really want to focus
on the film [__] I'm having fun with it
and I wrote my first script with my boy
and it taught me a lot I pretty much put
myself through film school just by this
the FX uh situation in this I'm learning
a lot about writing and I always have
other ideas I just never knew how to put
on paper but now I know how to so yeah
it's like the if it's the like Pinnacle
for a creative person I think cuz it's
music it's the whole graphical elements
of everything it's art it's story it's
video it's everything combined when
you're doing something from that Stu
yeah even like the movie in Montana
Flathead I'm not going to talk about too
much but Flathead is about to be dope
it's going to be a good horror film like
the horror films have all been really
really shitty they're very they're all
the same it's so little kids like
looking nervous and like see something
that someone else doesn't see or like
[__] some [__] haunted ghost or
some want to do like a [__] reality
[__] slasher dog like some Son of Sam
[__] but like way more Graphics some
real [__] that could actually really
happen you know MH I'm with it I love
super extra graphic
just I just trying to laugh scary movies
[__] with me but I can't do them man I I
I'm the only one that doesn't go to Hol
like we're missing graphic film right
now like even like the film I'm doing
like it's kind of edgy bro like Splash
it is a little edgy even like the
language like people are oh man they're
saying this and that I'm like bro it's
what it really is though like what are
we going to keep sugar coating [__] like
we need a more amense Society kind of
vibe we need like is like a kid yeah
it's like no really Splash City like
it's like New Jersey Drive meets [__]
juice honestly that's all right that's
what that is M Splash New Jersey drive
and Paper Soldiers most slept on
constant you
got on DVD still at the house Paper
Soldiers what is that one Kevin Hart
Charlie Murphy beanie seagull I've never
seen it man go watch preaches I still
hav't watched I'm watch it tonight s
what's on Amazon Prime or what I don't
even know I got the [__]
DVD part Rock CDs bro [__] bro well I
got blood in blood out on DVD so if we
need to swap real quick or something if
I you still haven't watched blood and
blood out that's one thing you need to
you need to watch it's just it's great
as a movie buff if you haven't seen it
bro
it's great you'll keep playing yourself
yeah yeah yeah but three-hour movie man
like it's yo you uh I watched I love
that [__] have you watched that uh the
Martin scors the new one kill killer
flower you watch it I [__] with it I
like a lot it's a little slow but it's
educational it's the slowest thing ever
but I was hooked he's getting slower our
boy's got a little slower he getting a
little older but that shot in the fire
was the nicest thing of the Year even
the um the Irishman was kind of slow too
but it was good I like the Irishman yeah
what that's good I watch 48 minutes ago
bro what is that a here I still watch it
though I like I still watch it though I
watch it all the time a great movie yeah
but I was sitting there smoking Joy
going for
real I know hell killer Killer's kind of
dragged on to I was I was expecting like
a little more but I was like this good
though I'm going to watch again this
week it was a good learning
experience it was it was a good movie go
watch that [__] it was great it was
great um all right question how did you
uh not how what was it like getting this
Forbes cover [__] it was like a blessing
and a curse why I mean on one on one
side every businessman's dream is to be
on the cover of forbs you got
multi-billionaires that have way more
success than I ever have that didn't
make that cover because the cover is
about personality it's about taste it's
about success it's about Charisma it's
about energy it's about impact on the
world right so now everyone checks all
those
boxes uh so it's a huge accomplishment
you're like all right man I did it but
the curse is that everyone thinks you're
just [__] stupid rich and you could
just pay for everything and you're
answer to everyone's problems and it was
like when Frank Lucas wore the [__]
fur coat to the fight because it's like
all right now I'm on the cover of for
bro you got what do you mean you ain't
got it I need it help me pay this pay
that help me with this bro bail me out
of this bro let me borrow this it's like
it just it kind of put perception on a
whole different level what success I
actually really have my success is like
I'm rich in spirit I'm rich in like
equity and one day maybe the equity
turns into liquid but right now I'm
still building my [__] so people felt
entitled to these billions they assumed
like man that fool you know back in the
day used to work with me like a lot of
my close friends got bitter brother like
it was weird like people I used to do
business with like man [__] ass
[__] ain't looking out for
everyone I'm like hold up bro nothing
has changed since this magazine came out
my dollar is still the same this is what
people are perceived on wor than they
actually low balled it a little bit if
I'm going to be honest with you but it's
still a lot of money for people to see
like oh what oh I should have been this
I should have this or I should have this
or why Ain he doing this for me it's
like bro first of all my overhead is
crazy and second of all like I work and
sacrificed all my time and mental health
to be where I'm at all I do is work I
was on the phone the whole way here I
woke up at 7:00 was on the phone all
morning on the phone the whole way here
but even when I pulled up I want to have
him like what up fool but I was like in
Middle Hing in my L turn it off like I
work my ass off so it was good because
it was like a big accomplishment
especially after cancer I was like damn
I beat cancer and got for like thank you
God wow whoever's up there m I love you
my video game player thank you good job
[__] good job trolling me Truman bro
thank you brother I'm sending one up
there in air for you right now smoke one
for you but also a lot of people got
jealous and envious of something that's
just someone's opinion of what I could
be worth my company sold that has a lot
of things have to happen we have to go
federally illegal I have to want to sell
my company I have to be in position to
still be that valuable when bro you're
counting Pockets first of all and then
you're counting pockets for like the way
big future yeah yeah yeah this is crazy
it's crazy so I guess it was a blessing
and a curse but huge accomplishment for
sure what kind of time frame do you feel
like personally we're looking at before
we just legal everywhere bro you want to
hear my honest opinion probably like 5
to 10 years more yeah no one wants to
hear that everyone's like oh it's going
to happen next few years no it's not for
real I thought it was going to be
hopefully next year no
brother here's the thing they haven't
truly figured out how to do it yet if
you really look at the Wii game just let
it go let's break down the fact Let it R
280 you know what that is what you call
is 280 you know what that is 280 I just
remember prop 250 man sell packs 280e is
a law that means that marijuana
operators can't write off any expenses
oh that shit's terrible no light bill no
employees no cost of nothing you're just
you are operating at a loss at all all
times so the Wii business is set up for
failure right now and the only ones
really lasting are people that got
really creative like me that figured out
how to do it without putting a bunch of
money into it and using our brand
leverage and our megaphone and what we
bring to table with this the genetics
and [__] or people that raise hella
bread right that are from like outside
traditional businesses
that's that also feel like the
government's trying to look and see
every way that it works out all right we
let all these people get in this failed
this we're taxing it from this level
this level this level but are we missing
money here or look at the way they did
over here they're letting different
states do it differently to kind of see
what's the best model the government
doesn't even understand what this is or
what this really does for everyone they
also don't understand how to tax it that
that people can grow it that people
should be able to grow it like they're
trying to figure out the business but
that's my honest opinion after being in
the for this long there's no other
reason why it wouldn't be legal already
they're trying to figure out the
business of it and there's some old
crinkly bastards that need to go before
it actually really goes and so I give
them 5 to 10 years till they're out new
generation got you got you because the
old the raisins don't understand it the
raisins were part of like all that rest
[__] race [__] uh division [__]
back in the days and [__] pot's going
to kill you like it's a whole way of
thinking that's just terrible it's still
there I it's still there they're very
old and wrinkly right now and it's a
matter of time time until they're out
the way and then when new people with
new thoughts and real life experience
come in that's when things would change
mhm yeah yeah hopefully we're just
waiting for that day on goddamn YouTube
because the same [__] you go through on
Instagram we go through on goddamn
YouTube soon as that happens this whole
new category is going to open up and
it's going to all be all good yeah I
mean bro like I've seen it I actually
really pay attention to so much more
than people think I watch what happens
to you guys on YouTube on Instagram I
pay attention to everything because I
give a [__] and and I make content as
well and and we've tried hella hard with
my page my page I can't monetize for
[__] but I feel like man
like just remember who drug you through
hell when all this [__] goes legal and
make them pay big for your [__] when
when they want it like [__] you
suppressed me for [__] 10 years you
[__] [__] [__] if you want my
[__] on here you got to Big bread cuz if
you make it through the turbulence and
you're still here when the [__] goes
legal yeah you're worse up exactly a lot
of people like [__] this bro I'm about
to go do this or [__] this I'm going to
go do this or [__] this I'm going to
start here I'm going to read it takes a
lot to want to still be in this kind of
space cuz it's very turbulent there's no
future and we don't know if we're ever
going to really hit or not but we we
stay in it so if you weather this storm
then [__] make sure you enjoy the sun
yeah so I like that yeah with this
federally legalization being so far off
I know you have a thca line mhm how do
you feel about this space because we do
the same thing we have dooba shop you
guys have the cookies TCA line how do
you feel about this being it's another
it's a whole another Lane should find
ways to Market in and kill it bro
because weed is
legalized under that law yes but weed is
not legalize federally for all the other
things that we do but thca no matter
what anyone says is just flour that test
a certain way growing in a hemp Farm you
have to buy it from a farm actual Farm
growing hemp you have to have hemp
license it's not too hard to get but you
have to apply for and you can only grow
hemp or you can only grow cannabis you
can't grow both so you can't have a farm
where it test low enough to be sold as
TCA that's illegal but federally the law
says that if you get a hemp license and
you get some indoor and you grow some
weed that tests under x amount percent
you could sell it IL legally in all
these states via mail we should trap or
die bro that's all it's about trap or
die legal Republicans Let It Go and they
legalize it there's places right now in
Tennessee where you can go buy buy weed
roll and smoke a joint have a drink and
go [__] buy ammo and [__] bust off
guns in the same building Christ in the
same building yes bro what is it called
I don't know cuz that sounds tight as
hell that's what I'm trying to do you
just basically said a bunch of [__] blog
it with you we'll go there but point
being is the point being is weed is
actually really legal right now but
People Like Us can't promote it because
our Instagram will get taken down our
YouTube will get taken down I wish I
could tell the world right now we sell
weed right now on the Internet it's
called TCA and you can get delivered to
your door and the quality of it is so
[__] fire it blows my mind it's just
it makes me go oh dude like but I think
there's there's three reasons there's
three reasons one we can't promote
it two people don't even really think
it's real bomb butd like this some like
back at the High Times magazine [__]
like dude no it's not it's pack it looks
just like this it smells fuing good just
test under a certain level and it makes
no sense that it's legal but it is fool
so buy this [__] and get it to your
doorstep in Virginia homie you're
tripping buy a pack or two [__] with him
[__] with me you got it it's kind of
shocking up and I know a lot of people
ha it on it and it's sad to see like
bigger players um there's a big group
out of Florida I'm not going to say
their name for political reasons but
they're backing
you know trying to get rid of this [__]
man leave it alone bro let the Trap live
who gives a [__] if you got good THC
don't worry about
thca and if you are a hustler just sell
both what are you worried about like
what are you really worried about so
about this on the internet officer
here's my receipt it's a very great area
I don't know how it works if you get
pulled over with this [__] I'm not I'm
not down to try it but I'm down to slay
this [__] and have loyers tell me it's
safe and that's what they told me yeah
exactly exct did people just realize
this is this like new news about the
it's I made a TCA video 5 years ago
dabbing that with the qpas of it they
just keep suppressing his ass bro like I
seen him doing it I seen him promoting
the shot but they keep deleting his
Pages deleting his Instagram his YouTube
so he can't promote it but it's been a
thing but they won't really let people
pop it off via the Internet so people
should really dissect this part right
here and be like you can legally buy
weed from a hemp farm that tests under a
certain TC level mhm and slang that
[__] to the mail yeah it's legal
federally legal you can put that money
in the bank yeah you can oh Farm Bill
shout out to farm bill you can shout out
to the farm bill yeah I got a tatted
right here in my head yeah I'm about to
get that I'm about to get that my
[__] first face that but the Shady
thing is that consumers don't trust it
they think it's going to be trash we
can't Market it properly and the lws are
kind of gray in some of these areas that
people are at they're going be like how
you really going to tell what this ACA
or not the note that comes with yeah
people don't want to explain that on the
side of the road type of [__] yeah that
could be it's hard it's hard but it's
like also you're going to go buy we from
some D behind Pizza Hut I seen a jar
taaca at my building yesterday I was
like dude I'm taking this home and
smoking this like unbelievable and I
have access to the best weed in the
world for not just me I'm not being
biased everyone givs me weed everywhere
I go I get weed I get I get weed I all
the weed M this [__] was so bomb I took
it home and I smoked it before I went to
bed I smoked when I woke up it tasted
good on the weight it burned good it
burned white ash it smokes good it got
me high as [__] there's no difference
than regular weed TCA it's crazy yeah
that's what he was been saying MH well
no the farm bill shout out to that for
sure shout out to the farm bill dog it's
pretty it's pretty uh it's pretty
shocking honestly uh when you see these
PS at TCA isn't it kind of crazy you
just walk to the car with that [__] when
I was in Texas when I was in Texas uh my
boy actually shout out to my boy uh
what's his name of his thing uh
the TAC Club I think in uh in in
Texas he has 13 stores he's trapping Tac
Taca hard he has 13 dispensaries it was
just on the news my boy raw and uh like
bro you ain't tripping he's like hell no
fool this [__] is legit he's like police
come in here don't give a [__] he's like
I just keep all my paperwork I I I only
buy from certified vendors I don't dab
why ain't selling up packs at the back
door it's like I treat this [__] like a
business and I'm able to bank my money
and guess what what so what he's like I
might even be able to get a loan for
this [__] from the bank I'm like
what he's killing it wow it's so stupid
like so matter fact you you have TCA on
Deck too yeah I'mma I'll put you in a
group text to this guy and he has he has
the best platform in Houston for this
[__] and all through actually Texas I
think Dallas as well hook him up he'll
buy a wholesale from you and he'll put
it in the hands of good smokers sick
yeah we just dabble we've had HC for a
while but we're dabbling into the thca
the past couple months and don't sleep
on it it's shocking how fire these we
these packs are here's the thing bro it
might stop the farm bill got extended
for like another year I think or
something like that a year or two years
year trap or die yes trap or for real
get it get it get it as long as you can
I'm about to get out of here when I
leave later and I'm on my plane I'm
about to text TCA to everyone I know get
it Popp we got one year to run that it's
a Ponzi scheme for real it's like hey
you want some we just [__] order then
I promise you I promise you it's I love
hearing you say it cuz that's how I feel
about it like I smoke fire every d d
this F's hash every day you know what SC
it sucks because the industry will make
you scared to say like that oh man
you're selling Taca [__] bums like no
I'm selling weed I smoke weed I've been
smoking weed as long as you guys are I
wouldn't sell some [__] now I'll
admit the CBD is not my Lane but people
like my father who has Parkinson's
enjoys the CBD flower we saw we saw CBD
fly through the internet and my dad's
Parkinson is [__] up bro and when he
smokes it he calms down a lot and it's
not too strong for him he couldn't
handle Taca he'd fall apart so like he'd
fall yeah it's too strong dude it's too
strong bro the Taca gets me just as high
as any of there's no difference there's
no difference it's just a certain test
level that's it I love it it's crazy you
heard it from both of these well you
guys are basically responsible for like
educating everybody on what it is it's
like the first wave of people really at
being kind of normal it it's kind
question like this is a question because
there's not a lot of other people on
Earth that I can ask this question when
it becomes to the like I said the little
15-year-old you there'll be times you're
sitting there by yourself I cuz it's so
small there's there's five people on
Earth you do content you do like
honestly you and you used to interview
people you were doing we to [__] before
wi to was a thing so let's just throw
that out there you were vlogging so
isn't it kind of wild sometimes you're
looking down just like no matter what
but if I stop doing this [__] right now
and I'm like 70 years old I in a grocery
store and I'm just like yeah bagging
[__] like hey are you burn like actually
that was a long time ago man my name's
Giller but yes it was fun you're always
going to go back like look at this
[__] picture of me with 9,000 lb and
like it's always going to be like the
little guy the little kid in you like
man I selling those 10 set I do too I do
too I love it I always think about like
I always joke with my my partner like
man oh all fails I just get a restaurant
job hey man aren't you burn I have my
little tow I am brother today special is
chicken Bata w w what happened burn hey
bro I fell off man it's all good but I
mean bro this spot's fire I'm glad you
guys came here you guys want to snap a
picture take a picture real quick boom
I'm comfortable with myself I'm rich in
spirit I did a lot of force scass [__]
but also you know at the end of the day
bro I think about like and I was trying
to get this spot before I remember if
you watch the documentary I did the 1111
documentary there's my real world
audition tape in there I was like
[__] 18 with the [__] little go
audition for the real world I was
[__] thought I was on top of the
while I was sitting there smoking in my
aition I bought a camera and I filmed
myself doing it I sent it into the real
world and I was smart enough to save it
until I made my documentary [__] five
years ago or four years ago or three
whatever it was who does that who who
believes in those Soul so much they're
going to film themselves and then save
that tape forever like this going to be
worth something one day uhhuh his BR
moved a hundred times I don't know where
my gold rings are I don't know my gold
bracelets are I don't know where some of
my cash I stash is but I know for sure I
had them tapes yeah and I know for sure
I pulled them out and it was important
to see that I'm like damn fool I was
dreaming on being on TV one day mhm then
I got all this now it's like and then
you're like I know I'm going to end up
somewhere so I'm going to hang on to
this I'm going hold on to this [__] I
got hella footage like that oh yeah
that's the good [__] important because
it's what inspires people when they look
at the story like this shit's not
overnight though talking about I've been
working since I've been a kid my first
job was [__] 13 I lied on my age with
that [__] Oscars handing out bread
sticks and [__] at a what's that it's
like a little Italian place 13 I see 13
I was do the move company I was just
trying to buy a car man I just want to
get a car I trying to get high man I was
selling weed too I was just trying to
buy a car I was that I need that weed
money man I need weed money and cool
water clone dog damn [__] czy up
pants I'm just I'm just trying to
imagine you've got let me see I'm go
through this's Instagram and he's going
to be exactly what I thought he look
like like a OG in high school a little
snow like a little fake player in high
school man I was not th gold thin gold
for sure cologne little baggy pants a
little I had the Turkish chain with it
little T little Turkish necklace s [__]
like that so you're from the
valley do do you notice that 99% of the
valley dresses like like you now you
noticed that it's the same look it's fun
bro come on man it's it's a it's the new
era of of people everyone gets high
every single person under 40 years old
in the valley smokes weed let me let me
give my weed people some inspiration
because again I said you know there's
benefits and there's pros and cons for
being on the cover of fors being on the
cover of for you get a lot of good
information from like highend business
people so we're on the Wei business it's
turbulent we don't we're silenc we're
making no money shit's tough but
cigarettes sales are down Big Time huge
M huge yeah I can imagine huge people
alcohol sales are down big time people
are choosing weed every day over alcohol
and cigarettes now cigarettes might be
to those little Vapes and [__] like that
but alcohol I heard the other day
someone was telling me there's a popping
bar in
Minnesota and the alcohol sales are
down 40% and people are buying Tac
infused drinks or TCA infused whatever
it may be whatever The Tweak is there in
Minnesota they're going to bars and
drinking this [__] cuz that's a law
there and and alcohol is down 40%
because of that that's crazy bro Jes CH
weed so much more fun people there was
there was a report that came out the
other day that said that people are
picking weed over alcohol all day all
the new kids like all these little young
kids cuz drinking is a [__] [__] show
it should have been opposite flipflop
the whole time like but that's what
these [__] were scared of and
that's why I said the raisin are almost
out of position they're the ones kind of
controlling that last little business of
tobacco and alcohol they're out the way
we're the new we're the new raisins if
we really think about it yeah but we
just won't be hating ass Raisins We
gonna be older like yeah man we made it
man oh there's some new [__] what is
that [__] called oh it's called K me for
sure man let it pop Let It Rock man do
it right like we going to be different
but yeah these guys got rich off alcohol
and tobacco they're super they're in
super position to keep weed suppressed
cuz we're taking over all their [__] and
they don't own any of us they're going
to try to and you know [__] we'll figure
it out but it's just crazy it's crazy
[__] we we actually really shook [__] up
so I feel like that's why people are
trying to silence our [__] mhm I mean it
makes sense yeah all right random
question do you think the 90s was the
best decade for football football you
grew up in San Francisco man the 90s was
your [__] come on what are you talk
you guys took over the 80s and '90s I
grew up a Packers fan in Merced
California my grandpa's a dieh hard ner
the whole room like like this it's
golden red Niners everything I don't
know why I grew up a Packers fan I had
to be honest man I just never cared
about sports oh come on not even growing
up in Frisco I mean I W Frisco because I
I wear the Giants I wear the Niners [__]
I'll even wear Oakland [__] I even wear
as [__] I'm all about support get it's a
bay I'm a barer boy but I've always
cared about grass cash and ass that's it
I want Women Weed and money I never
really cared about the sports I couldn't
watch I couldn't emotionally get
invested into grown men chasing each
other on the field like oh no I couldn't
do it man [__] it I want to go hang out
with the girl man [__] it but I get what
you're saying I get it but but in the
'90s the 90s was the best ERA in
general '90s was the best yeah we talk
about it off this show is called the
'90s
AKA you know probably the 70s was pretty
[__] good too
but we back then '90s was nice I feel
like 76 and 96 was just like Peak like
yeah music movies 2026 maybe we will go
legal no probably won't happen damn okay
hold on cuz I don't watch football at
all no more I fell off I do not watch it
but as a kid that's all I gave a [__]
about at WWF so I had to ask cuz you're
from San Francisco you grew up an hour
and a half away you know I'm a Packers
fan you're obviously a ner I just had to
ask but now I can't watch it it's just
million I call it it's just millionaires
playing a game which is cool but I'm B
like fake and [__] like that it's boring
now it's not the same no more I feel
like there's the superstars but like
those Superstars got Instagrams I don't
give a [__] about I'll go take my kid to
a game or something like that I'll take
her to like a Warriors game and enjoy
that like it's cool to Beall's different
yeah but I can't really watch sports on
TV it's not my thing don't I rather
watch Good Fellas have you uh had to
explain to your daughter the whole layer
of the weed world and your position and
all that [__] I tried to she don't give
a [__] she's like I want to hear about
that [__] she's like very good at just
keeping me Dad I'm just her dad she
knows she knows what it is she Highly
Educated she downplays her understanding
I know for sure she's probably way
smarter than I think she is but I spend
so much time with her that she she just
kind of likes to keep it like what I'm
like at home you know yeah mhm damn
that's good yeah that's how it's
supposed to be the same thing with what
a little brother I rais that full kind
but it's say how old is she she's
16 yeah she knows what's up she knows
what's up I asked her at school I was
asking her like two years ago people be
asking you for weeks I'm your dad she
like of course I'm like what do you say
she's like I I don't answer that [__]
I'm like all right cool I'm like I'm
just trying to see I'm just curious and
she's very to herself she's very
creative she's very artistic she's about
to be a boss for sure but she's she
downplays you know who I am at least
when I ask her she's kind oh whatever I
asked her to come to my show I'm like yo
Christmas I'm about to do a live manand
for first time I really want you to come
please and she's like okay I'll come and
then I she's like I don't want to go
like why like that's not really my thing
it's not my scene I don't I'm like I
respect that I respect least she know
what's up I respect that you know who
you are not feeling pressure cuz some
kids are like all right and go be
miserable like she like Dam I thing and
the fact that I respect it and she
respect I love that we have that
relationship yeah totally I was like man
I'm proud of you dude I'm glad you know
that you could have been there like you
could have been there [__] in a hot
box stressed out [__] that's another
thing maybe she knows what's going to
happen she know she said it was about to
be hella Smokey there I don't want to be
there Christmas yeah she knows what's up
and dude you not think everybody in her
school walks byot yeah tell your dad I'd
be a good model Con Bro yeah it's almost
like yeah I know my husband's a when
people like or their husband's wives
they do all that [__] I'm sure people
get tired of that [__] but I teach her
about all my business [__] though I'll
sit down with her I'll be like listen
today I went through this with this
person and this is what the outcome was
and I'll explain to her I'm like I'm
telling you this [__] because you're
hearing me now but you ain't really
hearing me now but like I show I show
this tattoo I'm like yo my mom was gamed
up I got a picture of her on the phone
here I heard her my whole life but never
really heard her until now mhm if you if
you know what I mean like mama's boy
best friend that was my that was my
guidance through life that was my
spiritual [__] savior she made me who
I am but I didn't really learn what I
was learning around her until I got
older I'm like damn she was really she
was on that phone talking that [__] she
was making moves like she was she was
good she really handed herself well she
was a good personality like I think I
just teach my daughter in a way that
like she can understand later yeah so
I'm like yo this is what it looks like
with this
if this ever happens this how I
accomplish this I'm just trying to give
her a game cuz she ain't really hearing
it but she's hearing it yeah it's
getting stored in there for later for
sure it's like a backup a hard drive M
you just give you some game and she'll
she'll be like okay what I'll tell her
she like okay and you can say she like
really she's like what are you
serious oh and like I see her thinking
about it and she's she's going to store
it yeah yeah yeah it's important that's
your job cuz she's watched you go from
you know nothing to something that whole
that whole seen it she seen she seen the
[__] she was with me in the albums that
you have at your at the house like she
was there in the room I'm like hey I'm
put on your show be quiet real quick
I'mma press me I'mma rap this real quick
I have my mic there with the sock on the
mic in the room recording myself doing a
lot of those albums doing my [__] I
record my [__] and bring it to to Jack
or bring it to quip or whatever she
would sit there and watch me rap and she
like I I'll like [__] try to run B stop
Ming up stop Ming up Dad watch show do
it I'm like okay okay sh one more time
every time I redo a take cuz I couldn't
punch myself in I know not do that [__]
it's [__] high operating [__]
computer she was she was a ball player
she played ball man like she came to
meetings with me when I built cookies SF
she came to like all this [__] she's
seen it all so she's game the [__] up
yeah for sure she's gonna be running her
own [__] Marty's got three k how old is
15 uh yeah about to be 15 right oh about
to be 16 I'm at that weird age of like I
like terrified of her driving and being
with other kids that are driving and I'm
also sick of [__] driving her
everywhere and want her to start
driving that that's a weird Middle
Ground cuz you're like you know how kids
drive you know they can want to go get
into weird [__] so you want to kind of
know but then you want them to have
their
freedom it's tough being your parents
hard yeah yeah for real you got to be
involved yeah well that's something for
you guys to deal with I'm not going to
be dealing with that [__] right now I'm
good I just have too much weed stuff I
want to do I just I love boxing my house
I love not worry about anybody else but
my my wife I'm like oh you're good we're
good but you know me and my girl were
talking about like even when my baby
comes I have to step on the balcony
that's
it you know smoke in the backyard I get
it smoke in the backyard my I think I'm
just I'm not there I worked for free for
nine years I just started being like Oh
I can live but let me give you some game
though trying let me give you some game
16 years ago I felt the same way and
that's why I had that panic attack when
I when my girl told me but it made me
step my game up hella hard on business
it gives you a different purpose on like
seeing all this sh do on a way that
makes sense for you and your family it's
like a different survival kind of
instinct you're like oh [__] shit's real
mhm like here's little y right here
little YOLO I got to get it cracking man
[__] look as much as I love doing this
for free you guys going have to pay me
this cuz otherwise I can't make it make
sense yeah you know what I mean like
it's going to make it's going to make
you become more of a business stus I get
that I I guess that does make sense cuz
everybody that always says that you just
step up your other [__] but at the same
time like just give me a couple more of
these years a luxury of watching Happy
Gilmore boxed in the house just D and
laugh I just need it for a little bit
and then and then we'll get into it man
I'm not there yet we we gonna We going
to going to be there man how old are you
again 34 man have a little baby ah not
yet man with techn what was it more
technology I think it be to 200 I can't
tell nice I I I'll live to be 100 if I
could mhm bro I'll live I take me to 300
as long as I'm killing it and I don't
look like disgusting I'm down you guys
aren't down they're like yo take this
pill you stay where you are right now
and you're like Wolverine I've been
thinking about whether I'd be down or
not to put my uh connect my brain to a
to a um to you see how they're saying
all this [__] about like you can
download your thoughts and this oh hell
no not now obviously now but as I get
older I'm Wonder like if they have this
kind of technology to kind of keep your
conscience around like I'm like would I
do that [__] or not I don't know I'm
thinking about I get high think about
you spend this whole lifetime Gathering
all this knowledge you know then it's
just gone to be able to upload that [__]
my conscience that I'm dead starts
throwing out really good zingers and
jokes they like it wasn't even him it
was his [__] conscious but it was a
robot like no that was me [__]
I'm a rob you ever SE Demolition Man I'm
I'm CAU I'm caught up in that [__]
though too cuz I feel like when you die
actually go somewhere mhm but if they're
trying to get you to store it maybe you
don't go somewhere you stuck in
purgatory forever like Black Mirror epod
think about this though think about this
though we all know that when you die
something happens many different
cultures around the world have said that
someone's came down they taught them to
way and if you do well you go up
right I don't I don't know how people
could have communicated if they're over
here over here and over here with no way
to travel all those years ago right but
they all had the same story so the
reason why I say I've been thinking
about was like okay well if we all know
you die and go somewhere and people are
trying to say modern day te technology
can keep you here with your conscience
or your thought maybe it's keeping you
from going somewhere else I don't know
give give a high right now say at hour
three we always get to that afterlife
bro and I we just hit the third three
hour mark That's when we get into
afterlife like I don't know I happens
you three you it's been 3 hours I've
held my piss for 3 hours yeah I'm just
saying like that's when it goes hey go
what you think about
no that's a good health sign too that I
don't even have to piss it's been 3
hours that means my blood sugars are
well oh look at you you're going to live
a long ass time like 100 no my my
9-year-old boy asked me these questions
like genuinely and then you got to
realize like oh [__] do I have answers
for these things what are my thoughts on
this cuz I never think talk about this
[__] out loud but yeah I think like
personally on a frequency level you kind
of just like you're saying yeah like you
don't want to get halfway caught up on
Earth still yeah hell level you're not
really suppos if I'm supposed to go
somewhere I'm going dude [__] what is
that this is like a new little candy
cross you know people like these candy
turps right now like I I know they do I
like a lot of green different kind of
creamy like skunky like funky weed but
this is what people like brought this
for you guys this is my recommendation
this is like good like when people come
to your show roll this up give it to
them smoke kind of change this oh you
just worn Marty's heart right now yeah
these these jars are more like heady
jars these are like small batch all
organic stuff that we're going at
cookies Maywood these these right here
like this is like a good like I'm
actually rolling for myself right now
but it smokes really good it's just a
good chain smoker but you can't smoke
this head shell time it's pretty
bum damn it looks just like candies yeah
I'm going to have a whole candy wall in
my new store cuz people just want candy
it's like a gassy candy smells just like
it I've seen this strain we've talked
about it we've seen two people go yo
this shit's fire it's clean as it's the
same exact cut it looks just like it
it's dusty almost like the Mac one it's
it's like Sandy it's yeah it's Sandy on
the outside you can you can break it up
just like this damn near yeah look at
the fingers look at yeah exactly look
exactly s how many joints are you
burning through a day do you think it
depends like my kind of vibe like if I'm
chilling creating I smoke back to back
to back to back if I'm chilling at the
house I mean I guess I smoke a lot I
guess it just really depends if if I'm
comfortable I smoke a lot more if I'm
like in a like trippy environment like
if we're on the whip going somewhere in
a different town and [__] I might be a
little Cy for a little bit but when I
once I get in my zone I just back to
back
it well oh thank you for the [__] man
we appr this [__] is appreciate what you
say this is this is the new tester yeah
it's just like some little candy [__]
out of R&D little candy just like good
little well Mari loves
R&D these These are this one is a Gary
pton cross is a Gary pton shery this is
a Serial Mo Sher Z this one is about to
be probably one of the next big ones let
it burp a little bit it's fresh I had in
TR for you yesterday for us yeah it's
for you I actually played you I kind of
smoke half of it hey no I appreciate it
man I was like man let me get some [__]
from my boy real quick bring some gifts
and then they brought this I was like oh
my God it's done oh yeah I'm like can I
get a pound of it they're like yes I'm
like when wait I'm not I'm going home
I'm flying I'm like [__] should I take
this J to Yola I'm like [__] it take the
pound anyway was that take the whole
pound anyway on the plane I I'll get it
I'll get it it'll be fine n dude we we
already talked about I'm so high can fig
I was grinded uh we already talked about
my issues with the thing wait what
happened here like this other way flip
that just flip that
up T
Jang this how it goes there you go there
you go got you that [__] is solid no
she's done good for me right now but uh
anyways I'll get the pee I'll get the
pee for it the [__] is going on here
what happen let me see let me see let me
see help me I'll show you I'll show you
what happened watch this what happened
let me see this my question are you uh
the the 11-11 Supper Club I've seen it a
couple times in your post are you into
numerology uh well that's my mom's
birthday oh okay 11-11 is my mom's
birthday my dad was born on 1 one so I
just feel like man that's my higher
that's my spiritual little you know
protectors right there I seen a post
other day it said be careful what you
[__] with because there might be people
out of this universe protecting them I
believe in that mhm so I just kind of
honor my mom's birthday and there's a
lot I've never really read read what
11-11 means I just know it's my mom's
birthday and I know there's something
behind that number I never really want
to read too deep into it cuz I actually
just enjoy celebrating my mom my mom's
birthday CU I wouldn't be here without
her but yeah 111 Supper Club should be
pretty interesting and what is that
that's new right yeah so basically what
I want to do is I have my building I put
a lot of money and time and energy into
my building and I get so much R&D stuff
from new gentics that were popping stuff
that were breeding in house stuff that
my friends breed I have an abundance of
weed all different kind of flavors and
I'm a hoarder I'm a hoarder with my weed
I can't give it away or do you have like
[__] from 3 months ago you're like I'm
not going to smoke it right now but I'm
going to smoke it I don't care if it's a
little old listen to me bro I'm a
hoarder with weed it's a problem it's
problem I thought this concept is it all
jars just forever I was like all right I
have this sick ass building I put all my
energy into it all my good memories are
coming there it's a good creative space
people always want to come and see this
building what if I host private dinners
here for like a yearly membership I pick
30 people and they get to go through R&D
stuff with me personally right help me
select strains help me name the strains
get to try the [__] that will never grow
again get gift bags when they leave of
stuff that we're cultivating [__]
with at the same time and they get to
eat a fire ass meal from one of my
favorite chefs or myself like that would
be a pretty cool experience if I was a
pothead I'm gonna offer this [__]
membership and I'm gonna see what
happens and I think it' be cool because
one I need some extra lungs two I think
that like there's some player like
player [__] like that missing it's only
30 people you know they get to come
probably like four times in a year to
kind of come chill smoke butt eat good
meals Network I mean and I think the
other people there are going to be good
Network for them too so I'm going to see
what I'm going to see what it does cool
idea that is is a [__] cool idea it's
really to burn through your weed it's to
burn through my weed to share this
experience with other people I see so
much good weed I never see again and
like you know how your Poss like
remember that [__] Panama Red or that
[__] the tii stick man well that's
like that's like that times a thousand
for me I see all kind of like remember
that rs13 [__] 599 or n or the bbpc
and they're like what you're psycho I'm
like no I'm not so I want to share these
good flavors with people I want to share
this good food with people and I started
doing hell cooking content and having
figured out how to monetize it I'm like
man [__] all this trying to figure out
how to monetize online I'm about to
monetize in real life and let people
experience some player ass [__] and cook
for some people and smoke some good bub
with him and have private Kickbacks did
your dad still cook yeah so that's in
you is that is that why you're doing
this because your dad taught you this no
I never really learned from him I just
wanted to cook cuz he cooked and
cooking's
good that some Forest gum sh cooking's
good no my nephew 6 he asked me last
night you like to cook I was always
getting some [__] out of the fridge
like bro
this is like you know why I like to cook
though bro I'll be like this I'll be
like I want a fish taco right now I'm be
like who sells fish tacos if I adore Ash
your fish tacos is going to be soggy and
smell like some wet yes it's not going
to be good if I if I [__] go
somewhere they might not have the tur
I'm like I can go buy some fish marinate
this [__] cook this [__] right here
bust down the Cabbage myself make the
[__] cram on myself do I can make it
the way you want it go to restaurant
you're like man this [__] sucks oh of
course I'm just like I watch so I watch
top I watch all that g random [__] I'm
like yo I bet you I can do that and then
I get it and go that [__] turned out
terrible nah bro I [__] suck at
putting [__] together that I see when I
can just make some random [__] I used to
work at the pizza spot but you can't
[__] up with
pizza nah man cooking is good bro it's
cool it's cool I'm just saying I think
I'm just my my ADD is just like yo I'm
bored as [__] waiting for this [__] once
once you get into it you're never going
to get out of it I can't wait to get
home and cook something tonight [__] I'm
about to bust down some good SE bass or
something so I want that in my life man
this will kadas like no other though all
right this if you got cheese from a bag
and you got tortillas for a bag Marty is
Gordon rsey Chef that it up right there
and Chef it up is you could you can
really and girls love when you can cook
too I love that [__] well he's married
I'm married my wife cooks hella of [__]
so I think I'm I just try she just
teaches me I just learn how to cook
she'd be so impressed but that's what
I'm saying the wies are happy when you
cook oh God how I make [__] it's just
I'm not good her Rosie Cooks crazy [__]
dude man come to the cozy kitchen for
for three days we going to teach you a
couple dishes according is that your
[__] yeah come to the cozy kitchen we
going to teach you a couple recipes
we'll have a couple of our guys come
down show you some [__] you come back
home and the wife you would be really
happy you going to bust down dish you be
like wow like yeah I mastered them
mother it's not just like that [__] up
my wife really looks at me like mentally
challenged when it comes to cooking and
[__] like wow this is great like if I
came home with know one how to make some
[__] yo it's okay Mar you're from
Buffalo bro it's
okay chicken vegan from Buffalo bro it's
all good oyst mushrooms dog yeah bro
right it's like fried chicken BR you
make him crispy if you if you SE Mar I
marinate my carneada bro and put that
[__] on the flat top get him
crispy put some couple peppers on that
base with some [__] crispy chili
garlic oil and some chabata bread my boy
some grilled onions that [__] PoBoy yeah
I I ate that [__] yesterday uhuh all you
got me all [__] hungry now all right
here we go you we've been here for three
hours we talked about the afterlife
talked about racism in
Arizona spit they call me SP and threw
an egg at me um
terrible all your life news comes in
cars we heard that like all the big news
comes in
cars uh what else what else have we we
we talked about got the Farmers Market
got the farmers market dropping trophies
just came out cookies on Melrose
dropping we got Splash City dropping
City yes we talk about we got the 111
Supper Club dropping 111 Supper Club on
the way 30 people let's go when when
does that open to what to the when do
people open up I'm probably going to
drop the submission so people have to
submit a video and explain why they
should be a part of the oh so it's not
just like people sign up okay that's I
was like yo you going have 30 you 30
just random people no I'm going hand
select the people I get enjoy these
experiences each year because like
they're real world interest no cuz
they're coming into my home I'm going to
bring them to my home essentially this
is my home this where this is where I'm
at so I have to at least feel your Vibe
out and want to hang out with you this
is not like you it's not a meeting GRE
this is very intimate we're going to
smoke bud together we're going to cook
together we're going to chill together
like this ain't like uh come here and
say hi to burner and Dick we we're about
to kick it a couple times so I want to
find some dope people to kick it with M
have to submit your video that's cool
you got to yeah you got to film yourself
watching all the videos doing all the
[__] behind man watching some of those
auditions was crazy yeah how many did
you get cuz you got 20 what you say
22,000 auditions for SP City how many
did you get for people all right hold on
if you want to get people come act hey
you want to come get high as [__] and
eat food with me how many submissions
did you get we limited it to 10,000
people only 10,000 people can submit the
video we already learned our lesson but
10,000 is so much I know but I'm start
off every video
everyone's going to try to be calm for
their hopefully that we drop the
application before this drops and then
people are going to get Gand up on how
to act but I'm really going to select
some VI people that's it m i want to
know knucklehead that's what cool man
that's that's add to the conversation
and people players to man who who's
going to appreciate this good look at
that [__] I rote that a little
more traditional you know end it with a
bang show I got skills end it with a
bang see that's why I roll those those
last year I'm like uh I make them
straight but usually bro they're just
hog legs and that's fine with me this
this [__] is actually really good bro oh
I can really see how I try to hate on it
cuz it's candy but I love candy though
you do if it smokes perfect and it's got
to be perfect be okay nice and white
nice is that what's in here uh that's
cereal mode and
then it's kind of tasty how do so you
click once and blue will be serala mode
and then you click another time and red
would be cereal milk and then you click
twice and both colors flashing will be
both at the same time
so do you foresee another 10 20
locations open up in 2024 oh [__] I'm
put weed everywhere I'm put weed
everywhere brother so wher we can find
the right kind of Partnerships or
wherever we can be first to Market and
Brands you know spaces where other kind
of like limited market companies are
kind of dominating we're going to be
there anywhere we can go we're going to
go cookies
Buffalo
Marty you from Buffalo yeah he's from
Buffalo Conway RPS while I just actually
wrapped about Buffalo last night no [__]
yeah caught a bar caught a bar yeah we
had we had Betty the butcher in here and
they were just talk like it was just
essentially like hey you want to just
talk about like hell of [__] we know
from the same town it's like when I had
GB on here like you know on Third Street
where that [__] place is that where
all those game it was you guys where all
your homies are GB basically is dope doe
they're all dope all dope bro GB is dope
too cool ass dude uh there's a lot of
people coming out of cnia right now I
feel uh especially I'm surprisedly for
the valley a lot MH and we did the event
there there was a lot of uh FS from
Stockton Stockton got a popping right
now right on the rap shet it's pretty
crazy it's it's dope to see a little
Resurgence and [__] from our area yeah
because it was cool for when I was in
high school and then it just fell off
it's the one little area hip-hop that I
never I [__] was just a student
everything but the Bay now that I'm like
following thler and I'm like super aware
of everything like the whole culture of
it it's like it's cool you know I was up
on all hip-hop I knew the Jacka only
because he was featured on a core Mega
mixtape as a bonus track and I was like
that was like my favorite [__] on the
whole CD basically but other than that I
mean I knew
the Too Short Course big ones but like
like I said like the underground [__]
the fools that are never on the radio
that's that harsh like DS and and and
the uh all the records damn I'm [__]
Blake here what was his name I mean
obviously Jay stalins and
damn come on help me out what's this
[__] name Filthy Rich it's not Filthy
Rich it's filthy rich adjacent it's like
it's those whole it's like that group
there was one I got I got two of his
albums I can't remember his [__] name
Jo blo
no he's got he's got
transs a I feel so dumb I'm G find out
the second we end this podcast I
remember come on man Shady Shady Nate
thank you Shady 380 appreciate it thank
you thank you thank shout out to my e
man here thank you appreciate it I used
to get all his albums from so fresh all
of this [__] just uh sh man yeah he did
his thing for sure for sure man hey that
I I kind of take this back you guys
should probably just smoke that to
yourselves too I thought it was like
it's candy weed so I was like yeah just
smoke this with your guest but this [__]
that sh burning right therec it's
burning very Caucasian but tastes really
good I love it I'm I'm going to be like
that shady Uncle quick let me take one
more you know me see that back back
don't worry Marty's going to power smoke
through this I'm going to be like Lefty
in [__] uh [__] what's that movie
called um [__] what's his name Johnny
Depp
uh it's three hours in bro he's an
informant giant de Donny bras I'm be
like left D I'm give you an envelope and
take it back it's all good it's all good
appreciate it you brought some [__]
weed for us that's dope well thank you
[__] what you guys going end up eating
after this that's my question for you
guys for I dip where you guys going what
do we eat after this I'm to go somewhere
shady I already know is that taco truck
to be trusted outside we're going to
have oh no no stop stop stop stop
stop motherucker don't bu don't support
that local Taco Truck damn it no don't
support that man he's a [__] he's
super rude to me [__] that guy it's a
whole situation the whole situation with
that man I won't spend my money with him
don't he's not a nice person I'm super
nice to him you're still rude to me [__]
him sorry to get back on the positive
note there's some spots around here but
I don't know bro I just hit uies
cuz I don't know there's nothing around
or Hollywood and [__] yeah we're going
to go find some heady we're going to
[__] stumble in somewhere this fo
would know if there was some many [__]
around here there's nothing but uh no
dude I appreciate you being here this is
so legendary we appreciate it the fans
are going to be so excited I'm excited I
appreciate you guys putting out that
post too that day cuz that got me to hit
you up and actually Kenny Powers got me
to hit you up so shout out to my brother
he hit me up too Powers up you know so
you know at the end of the day he
connected dots I appreciate you guys
youve been doing your thing for a while
I've seen you kind of you know come come
past all the suppression on Instagram
and YouTube and keep pushing just know
it's going to pay off one day cuz I do
the same [__] I have to tell my [__] s
the same [__] every every day it's day
out big time cuz you've already
weathered the storm so what else can
happen and I always thinking this
whoever's out there doing it is going
he's going to give up one day and I
can't let that F they have a little dick
they're they they eat Spam with no
[__] ingredients they probably drink
Mountain Dew and smoke Maro red still
they're they're very miserable people
these guys at the same time though they
they probably haven't had love in many
years they something's wrong no for real
because we ain't doing nothing
intentional nobody in a harmful way
they're miserable people and at the end
of the day we're shining we're doing our
thing we're having fun doing it that's
all matters so good [__] I'm probably
going to steal this Grinder from you
I'll I leave
I I have two jars of weed for not like
this I got two weeds from you from my
homies thank you appreciate thank
Marty's Marty heart so my Grinch hard is
one yeah just moving now PP case of De
stud
fans all good boys we sh my I appreciate
you man um so suppressed ass Instagram
where can everybody find you burner 415
burner 415 man I'll be there you got to
type it all the way in yeah you have to
type all the way for it to pop up just
like you won't see my stories and my
post so come check on me please I love
for you check just come say hi to your
uncle your Theo you know I'm still here
baby all right well about Twitter cuz
their Twitter's Twitter's chill I'm
saying baby 4 five oh you got it all
across yeah I got it across see that's
what happens when you you you have like
oh yeah man I make music I do this yo I
just sell backs tell stories over here
give yeah you can get in the building
but you know what I want to make it our
mission cuz you are a big influencer you
have a big platform uh think about
social club bro when I do these kind of
sit Downs when I me up look at this I I
do business with people so maybe that's
some we could do if some you're
interested in getting some equity in
bringing some other good influencers in
so when I meet people and I have sit
Downs with people it's a great
conversation but I always try to figure
out ways we could do something together
so with that being said we only let
Instagram suppress us because we resort
to going there but I felt like we just
both took a strike said if you want to
see me I'm about to be on this platform
for this much months and I could
sacrifice at least that many months at
bringing people over and I don't think
it's just on me and you I'm about
thinking about doing Equity pool I'm
about to hit NBA young boy I'm about to
hit up a couple other people that want
to be a part of something dope and that
had big influence so think about it so
Club is there i' i' I'd give you some
equity in that and I i' let you rock
with us because it's going to take
multiple people to get that popping but
the second we do that we have our own
plat platform to talk our [__] and do
our thing 30 minutes before you got here
what do we talk about it has to take
everybody to boo at Woods yeah everybody
has to agree to go we're going to
support this thing at once and not a
fight not a cool thing it can't be two
people it can't be three people 15 20
people I about I was talking about the
Canabis community in general just that
would get it has to be every single
person all at once wanting just to do it
well here's the thing about social club
if you're a cannabis company I forgot to
mention this to you as well my brother
if you're a canus company you can upload
your menu for free on social club it's
in your bio click your menu option and
you can put pictures of your product
with the price that you sell your [__]
for you can't buy it there because
showcase your [__] similar to Wei Maps
right you could do audio comments right
you could do story you could do Post you
could do geotag locations you can see
what's going on three miles six miles 10
miles right we have live coming soon and
I feel like bro also I'm the one that
verifies people personally so if you
sign up today I'll verify you and no one
else can get topas Yol ever because we
got it no one else can pay to delete you
because I don't believe in that paid
play [__] punk ass [__] and also
we're about to put some new technology
in that says anyone has dope
ad is just not going to be able to make
an account cuz I hate going Instagram
put burner and there's 100 burners and
old Ladi are getting scammed and [__]
like that so we're going to put some
kind of technology in there it stops
fake accounts that's the biggest problem
what's wrong with Instagram what's wrong
with Twitter scammers let's get these
[__] out of here so you're
thinking about people that built their
business from the social media world
right about to build a social media
platform understanding everything that
people like yourself and new upand
cominging people need so we're on it bro
so Social Club you push me I'll push you
let's push that because honestly is
right there for us I don't even use it
I'm guilty I'm sorry to my thousand
3,000 people on there I love you thank
you I'll be back tonight download the
app I'll verify you I'll verify you and
campus companies can put their menus up
we should [__] with it dude we're
playing ourselves right now all right
it's all so frustrating
like spending so much time on [__] to
post for people that are following you
for your community just you know like I
hate building something and getting it
taken from me dude yeah it's the [__]
worst and I hate that someone could
decide
when someone can see my [__] I hate that
I look at a flyer and say damn my
homeboy had a birthday party yesterday
it's his birthday what the [__] why did
it show me this two days ago yeah why do
it show me two days later also Social
Club is in chronological order yeah
that's what it should be real it used to
be I would what Instagram used to be I
post see something is happening right
now in real time all this let's show
people Pizza ads today it's like no dude
[__] [__] what's my boys
doing right now what's
popping feel all right so Social Club so
you can post weed I'm not going to get
deleted no all right and the big thing
I'll keep it real with you I ain't going
to delete competition I went to all the
people that consider themselves
competition with social club launch and
offer them a verified page and try to
lock their names and I don't care about
none of that [__] we all eat I'm I'm
very comfortable in my skin so you're
not going to have someone that I'm going
to create a system where like only the
way you can get deleted from Social Club
is you post like dick pics or [__]
cocaine or pills or something I don't
want that [__] on there otherwise
everything goes that's why we took our
app down it was tooo much of that it too
much man it was going cool for a while
it was just there cuz nobody all these
apps supressed us we're like hey I'll
give you I'll give you a little bit of
game and I'm a row so my boys don't kill
me but I'll leave you guys with this
social club when I first launched in
2019 jumped to the number one app on the
App Store yeah I thought I was doing
something right what happened was people
were so [__] upset that I had my own
platform to do what I have to do they
send in a bunch of bots to post dick
gorgeous porn and [__] drugs and Coke
and all kind of [__] got my [__] removed
right they put a bunch of fake users on
there hit my [__] hella hard I was like
oh my God Social Club is number one
happen oh my Tik Tok and all this [__]
then I got in app and start seeing all
this [__] it took my [__] down three
days I took three years off I rebuilt it
I put a bunch of technology in the
background that's protecting us from
that [__] so if someone put [__]
shady [__] or [__] shady [__]
shady [__] blocks of Coke or fentol
or some [__] the the little AI blocks it
develop [__] yeah Happ it was dicks
and guns and and porn and Coke bricks
but like obviously from Google image
screenshot bricks not like anyone had
any bricks you didn't have no do in
Alabama big way exactly it was always
just some it was eight homies in a
Discord going hey you know be really
sick if we all did it the same time no
it was it was some [__] fake phones
in India and China just send that [__]
to your ass to attack but social club we
want we won't let any attack we
up no attacks no no war on social club
all right that sounds amazing I know
that's what we were talking about before
we got here download it when you when
when I leave check it out it it
functions pretty well and we're open to
feedback but it's just me and one guy
from China shout out to my brother Paul
he's been on big mushrooms Benny's been
my witness Noah has been my witness he's
been on big mushrooms he's been on DMT
he's been finding alternative ways to
keep us safe on social club oh God what
a job for him though came straight from
China dog my boy came out here oh he's
out here taking drugs he's out here
thugging it out I thought you I was like
this was in China taking all these drugs
he's probably one of the most brilliant
developers I've ever met and he's he's
sick as [__] we we got him to smoke weed
and he's opening his mind and he's he's
loving it I he's a legendary tech
developer and and he's he's [__]
brilliant so yeah you got him out here
that's awesome oh yeah all right well
you built a monster that sounds awesome
he's going to develop the new Skylink
what's it called stard right what' you
guys call that [__] earlier starlink
starlink starlink whatever spaceship
that was um so we uh UFOs
racism check check mark That's
everything we talk about on this show so
thank you for coming today I know we're
going to get out you we been there for
three and a half three and a half on the
dot this three and a half hours
appreciate every look at John he's never
sat for more than like an hour on one
thing he's dying inside everyone's
hungry everyone has to piss sorry all
right let's WRA up let's R sorry this
was more of a session in the garage my
bad um so yeah thank you for being here
this is a good moment man I think it's
finally finally happened I think it was
good appreciate you being here thank you
thank you let's break some bread in 2024
salute to you guys appreciate you guys'
platform you guys are killing it don't
worry about hater ass [__]
trying to suppress we will progress also
the last thing we'll leave it with trap
or Die trap or die dude caca dude by the
we support the [__] people taking the
[__] risk to do it and understand
it's back it is just weed wait hold
on there some ACA I had uh have you seen
this oh yeah oh yeah the same [__] all
right just just so we understand that
was the whole plot so is this actually
rtac there we go there we go all right
guys thank you so much appreciate you
from Marty from burner and I this has
been the dope as usual podcast it's been
three and a half hours so thank you for
hanging out with us have a dope ass day
y good [__]
[Music]
man perfect
perfect
[Music]